foreign
[Laughter]
hey you guys what's going on it's Friday
night yeah we're probably not going to
go out tonight probably just gonna
stay here
I'm being broke and y'all being broken
all being broken all I can't damn find
my glasses that's why we were late
starting she's like oh I forgot my
glasses and now we can't find it you
need to staple that [ __ ] to your head
because you're fine you lose them all
the time no
I went down there to make some lemonade
and it's the lemonade off the fresh
squeeze lemonade off the tree in the
backyard
it's the first time I eat uh made
lemonade with it we'll see what it
tastes like once we get done with this
first one
and then um I made lemon pie with it
lemon icebox pie it was good
when did when was that oh that's right I
forgot all about that that was like
about a week ago yeah that was like last
week or something I was like what you
made lemon ice Buck pie you're gonna
tell me
[Laughter]
that was last week though he's gonna go
try and fight his classes I don't know
how he keeps losing them he always loses
them all the time
Dave says hello hi Dave what's going on
we're probably are you going out tonight
probably we probably won't because like
I said I'm
broke as [ __ ] so you know probably have
to stay home and I don't know maybe
watch some more Wednesday we started
watching that last night that it's
pretty good actually
I had wanted I wanted to see it and then
like I went and hung out with my uh
sister my two brothers last Sunday and
all of them had watched it and they're
like oh Jenny you really have to see it
so we started watching it like last
night and it was really good we watched
like the first three episodes
I found where were they on a bit
and planted in it was dark see I had to
get my uh
my bat walkie-talkie see your bat
walking yeah because you're gonna talk
to some bats
it's got a built in why would you do
such a thing it just does that's what it
has yeah but I mean why why would you
turn it on and like
blinds people because that's what I do
that's the kind of [ __ ] I do you know
what I mean these things are [ __ ]
great though these the ub5 and the uv9
now twenty dollars by a hell of a little
walkie-talkie this is like similar to
the one that [ __ ] old McLean had on
the damn [ __ ]
die hard one it was like this this is
better actually
little ham radio
John Smith said it's too cold out
tonight is it not here it's not it's 80
degrees here well here by my little
temperature thing says 75. okay I mean
might as well be yeah you know it was 80
earlier today who's in here let me go
see everybody everybody's in here
everybody well I mean not everybody in
the whole world
laughs
yeah Wednesday's pretty good that's a
pretty good show
yeah like I said we've only watched the
first three yeah so you know also want
to see the um
Graham Hancock
um
series
what's it called everybody likes it
[ __ ] Connor Vaseline said I'd love it
it's got ancient apocalypse
evidently you gotta you gotta watch like
get halfway through the series each
one's about a certain thing and then
halfway through it they start blending
it all in yeah I've been I've been
listening to Graham Hancock since I was
a kid you know they put him on he'd be
on Art Bell
and I always thought there was something
to what he was saying then they are fine
that go back go back Lee tappy stuff and
you know anxious sites get that mankind
civilizations much older than we think
it is you know it goes further back than
ancient Egypt you know he's talking ten
thousand fifteen thousand years
maybe even 20 000 years
and if there was a he's not saying
industrial you know pre-industrial but
big you know on on the uh on PAW Patrol
or something
and uh
that all the world's
civilizations kind of came from that
some kind of big apocalypse happened
Jeff erart said I just tuned in to see
Tom shining a bright LED in my face I'm
blind yes yeah
I don't know why he does things like
that why did you why does he do things I
do what I do nobody knows nothing
happened today is uh
I got my Bane mask that's right it looks
pretty good it's just Halloween yeah so
I'm putting that I'm putting that um
costume together the mask looks pretty
good
um it's a little bit small for me I'm
trying to use a heat gun to kind of
stretch it and and make it shaped a
little bit better for my head I don't
know what kind of human being they used
I think it might have been made
in a size that's in between child and
adult so kind of like anybody could wear
it but it doesn't quite well yeah you I
mean usually Halloween costumes they try
to like make it so it's one size fits
the most type of thing yeah but it needs
a liner a lot of stuff needs to be made
for it to get to fit right well you got
time I got time I got a whole year to
work on it I'll probably add some
leather interior to it and some padding
to get the shape right and use the Heat
Treating and maybe like make it a little
bit longer in the back which would be
easy to do with the right material
and some colors need to be changed some
of the stuff's too silver it needs to be
aged you know so it looks like a worn
piece of equipment but it'll get it
right I'll get it right I'm mostly
worried about that vest
um
none of the reproductions look good to
me I have real bulletproof vests body
armor that would kind of work
um
but it wouldn't be movie correct
I could probably make something like
that out of that some of it's I'm
recognizing I don't know if you guys
remember the Bane's vest and another
option is just go without it because in
a couple Seasons he just walked around
shirtless
I'm already looking better than Tom
Hardy shirtless I could [ __ ] rock
that [ __ ] I came in I was looking good
man but I'd had to be like on I'd have
to be have to get my pump on
but if I put a couple more pounds of
muscle on in the next couple years it'd
look even better
do a couple more Tran Cycles
to have Jenny had to [ __ ] walk me
through it it's like shit's like [ __ ]
climbing Mount Everest
oh is it gonna be that kind of thing
again yeah maybe I don't know we'll see
we'll see we'll see you get emotionalist
[ __ ] I'm all emotional rollercoaster
yeah I'd be like Jenny you know I'm
sorry
you went all emo yeah getting all emo
and [ __ ] you know
I was talking to a dude at the [ __ ]
biker bar he was saying yeah man makes
you a [ __ ] then it says I know he says
were you crying on watching movies
crying no I felt like crying no just
thinking about you because yeah yeah it
makes you [ __ ] emotional and then I
had him in my world yeah and then I
[ __ ] I [ __ ] had him laughing and I
said I said imagine all those cows man
[ __ ] those cows walking around that
[ __ ] is cheating on me because yeah he
was thinking the same thing he thought
the same thing he goes man I bet you
those [ __ ] cattle those cattle are
constantly crying and thinking that
everybody's cheating on them and they're
jealous of everybody like yeah oh poor
cows those cows yeah
I don't know like they're like their
lives aren't [ __ ] rough enough you
know what I mean like it's like I'm
gonna get turned into a burger someday I
don't think they even have any concept
of that well you don't know I think
animals are kind of smarter than we give
them credit for it there's not much
braids on a cow they're a bit busy
eating grass it's probably just uh
they just
see another cow and I go that [ __ ]
[ __ ] cheating on me
God damn it bestie yeah
oh no I feel bad right she's leaving me
[Laughter]
for another Bowl yeah
it's just [ __ ] funny man [ __ ] Days
of Our Lives yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah
please tell me somewhere that somebody
has made like a soap opera that is all
about cows yeah the cow character about
these [ __ ] big big [ __ ] muscle
veteran bikers [ __ ] talking about
asking each other were you crying when
you took that [ __ ] yeah that's cute
though I like that I like that that
y'all were like admitting it yeah
because I feel like maybe a long time
ago like if you were going through that
[ __ ] like you would be too embarrassed
to tell anybody yeah yeah you're crying
and so like you probably think you were
the only one and that would [ __ ] you up
even more yeah yeah back before the
internet bad but yeah like now that
everybody kind of knows and it's like
there are notes yeah and they're and
they're not like there's not the same
stigma about it yeah so I think that's
like much healthier it's [ __ ] science
right that's what I mean chemistry you
know
that's [ __ ] hilarious yeah Jen and
Janice sof got me through that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
Texas soap and [ __ ] and the girls were
like well Welcome to our world this is
and I was like yeah I see it that's what
I mean and like I was I was talking to I
was talking to my friend Jen whose name
is also Jen yeah and I was talking to
her and I said something about the you
know you being all that stuff and like
being all like [ __ ] and stuff and she's
like so like we are all the time I'm
like yeah exactly
progesterone
yeah real high levels of progesterone it
sucks right yeah but like I said we
don't really I mean we're just like that
all the time and that's just kind of
like that's that's just the sea that we
swim in yeah and have since
puberty really it makes me not trust
women now
no I don't think that I don't think
that's no I don't think that's fair to
say well because the thing about it is
that you experienced it and it was weird
to you like to us it's not weird because
that's just like what our experience of
the world is like all the time and we
know that it's like that like so you
know what I mean like we know that
that's what's causing it the weirdest
thing about progesterone is that you do
something and then you question whether
or not you should have done it yeah no
[ __ ] and then you're constantly
questioning yourself I've done that my
whole life why do you think I'm like a
big [ __ ] ball of anxiety at all times
yeah it's it's progesterone it's not
real
I mean well the thing about it illusion
some of it is because some of it's real
because you know uh you know for let's
just take it like a random example like
if I had had like a discussion with
somebody and I said something that I
thought was kind of [ __ ] up and then
like later on I was like oh man I
probably said something that was like
really [ __ ] up or insulting or
something like that I mean it might have
been they probably did take it the wrong
way or some [ __ ] like so I wasn't wrong
about that I'm just saying that
sometimes it's sometimes you perceive
things correctly and sometimes you're
overthinking it that's all right but you
just but like I said not always not
always not always mostly you
it's not as important well and the thing
about it I wouldn't want to be
um don't take this wrong way but I
wouldn't want to be like a dude because
I kind of feel like dudes don't really
give a [ __ ] yeah and I don't think
that's good either because it's like I
would rather be like over anxious and
not you know and not be an [ __ ] to
people you know what I mean it's good
it's good for us
because if you do something you're like
well [ __ ] them I don't need them well
see that's what I mean I don't want to
be like that yeah well it's but it makes
you a lot more Bulletproof
well because you don't give a [ __ ]
because you don't care like I said yeah
but I don't really want to be like that
it's just kind of a thing where I don't
I was talking to my sister-in-law the
other day about
um being on like uh you know
antidepressants and stuff like that and
I've never been on anything like that
but I know a lot of people that have
been and they're basically like well it
just like numbs all your emotions and
pretty much every woman that I've known
that's been on that they did not like
that at all that's just like yeah I feel
better like I'm not anxious and stuff
like that but I don't feel anything like
I don't feel any Joy or anything like
that and that's like really shitty it's
almost kind of like a chemical lobotomy
that's what I mean so I would rather
just feel the whole range of emotions
like whether it's anxiety or happiness
or whatever
um even though it's like really
uncomfortable for me a lot of the times
because like I said I'm like really
anxious and I worry about a lot of
things but I would rather do that than
not give a [ __ ] about it really
serotonin reuptake Inhibitors I think
really really the only the only reason
why you should get give that to anybody
if you ask me is [ __ ] right after
some kind of pretty intense drama where
are you yeah and and combat related some
people got blown up and [ __ ] dudes
got killed right I could see yeah and
I'm not like if people want to take
that's fine but it's like I'm just kind
of like right and I don't think I would
want to do it and it's just to kind of
blunt the they have some drugs that
they're working with to kind of make you
forget
what happened too which I don't know if
I'd want to forget
I'm not like I guess if it kind of
brings on Amnesia the dude's [ __ ]
freaked out in combat they just started
juicing them up with all this kind of
[ __ ] and three or four days later he
can't remember what had happened you're
like no you don't want to remember that
kind of [ __ ] he's like okay and it's
supposed to I don't know if they're
still doing that they were experimenting
with it I don't think it's good not to
remember I think it's better to remember
I think it depends on the person I mean
and the thing about it I think that's
kind of where full disclosure would come
into view because they're like look we
have a drug
that will do this that and the other
thing you might forget all this stuff
like do you want that yeah
um you know here's maybe like the the
implications of that here's maybe like
the side effects of that and then like
let people decide if they want that they
were experimenting not with with it on
women who had been like looking attacked
like sexual attacks and stuff like that
that were pretty intense evidently it
worked they couldn't remember what had
happened yeah you know it might what
might be good for stuff like that
but living yeah something like super
traumatic I can see that that like you
that there was really no reason that you
needed to remember it was just like
messing you up right like I could see
that but most things it's like even
shitty things like I I don't know I
think I'd kind of rather remember
because actually if you hang around long
enough you usually forget it anyway
I'm trying to look at it from the point
of view of being you know ex-infantry
and stuff
if your buddies got blown up it's kind
of disrespectful to forget how they died
I think that's kind of how I would feel
too that you'd want to know whether or
not they died not knowing what happened
or if they died honorably or if they
died you know [ __ ] uh in a bad way
that you should be able to remember that
because that was the last of them you
know
yeah I think I kind of feel the same way
about that it's just kind of like how
you know when someone like a loved one
dies yeah and to me like you know when
I've had family members die and stuff
like that and it's like and it was
really really upsetting but in a way
like I don't know it's weird like you
feel bad like going on it's like you
almost feel like you're not allowed to
be happy again because they're gone let
me go get you some more ice and it took
me a while to like get past that but
then I was like well
I don't know like I guess the the loved
one wouldn't want you to be like bummed
out and like you know that they're dead
and everything but
in a way like you I almost kind of feel
like oh it's just like I'm forgetting
them and I don't want to forget them you
know what I mean so I don't know like I
had a really hard time like when my
grandmother died this is what I'm saying
um I was pretty [ __ ] up for a long
time and like I said I kind of felt bad
you know because I was really close to
her and I just kind of felt bad that
like going on with my life kind of I
think that's a pretty common thing like
when somebody that you love dies but
you know
but I get what you're saying I kind of
feel the same way about it I kind of
feel like it's a little bit
I mean you could you should feel like
you can like move on with your life and
you can still be happy again and like
not feel bad about like still being
alive like in them not being but I don't
think like forgetting them is like well
you know yeah if your buddy's got blown
up and then they're like final moments
you saw one of them trying to Shield the
other one right you know what I mean and
they both got vaporized
at least
you might want to remember that it's
going like yeah he tried to save the
other guy yeah you know what I mean
because that's kind of an honorable act
yeah try to remember like the good [ __ ]
right right you know what I mean and
you're erasing everything as if the as
if their death didn't matter
yeah John Smith said uh Eternal Sunshine
of the Spotless Mind stuff right there
man I still need to like review that I
love that movie so much have you never
seen it haven't you it's basically about
that where like they there's this um
like experimental Clinic that will erase
particular memories like of of people or
breakups if they're like too painful
it's kind of like Jim Carrey's in it but
he's really good in it you know I mean
it's Jim Carrey and um Kate Winslet it's
really really good Griefer says uh
you're giving those pills too much
credit Tom a head shrinker put me on
Zoloft after I responded to an execution
style homicide in 1993 it didn't do [ __ ]
and I stopped taking it after a couple
weeks yeah and I kind of feel like it
affects everybody differently too like
you know what I mean yeah I think they
were only designed to be a temporary
bandage anyway you weren't supposed to
live on them you're just supposed to get
through it you know blunt the trauma for
a month or so and then jump off for like
a hard time yeah yeah
um
blunt the emotions a little bit which it
may or may not work probably depends on
who it is you know who it is and then
somebody in there said that you can make
I should make my own version of that
mask
well
I looked at that
there's a lot involved in it and if I
were to make another version of that if
I were to make my own version of that
mask I'd probably need pieces off of
this one
you know because there's some things
that on this mask that are good enough
but really the only the only problem
with this mask is that it doesn't have a
lining to it that
hope that feels good against the skin
and holds it in a kind of a proper shape
and it's a little bit too small I could
adjust it just a little bit it'd be fine
yeah I mean I think it looks good to be
honest another interior yeah with just a
couple of um tweaks right I think it
would look really good it only needs to
be a little bit give me a little bit of
room like a quarter of an inch on either
side to make it kind of slip down a
little bit lower on the back of my head
it's up a little bit too high and I may
be able to do that with a heat gun just
get a heat gun get real hot stretch it
and then hit it with cold water to make
it freeze that size to make it a little
bit bigger
um I used a heat gun on it because it
had been balled up
and when it came out of the package it
was all bent but I just hit it with the
heat gun and it all relaxed you know
it's it's actually a decent mask yeah it
just needs a little bit of TLC a little
bit of finish work on it
um see Pookie like running around yeah
what you doing crazy
Zach says uh I tend to bottle up my
emotions which I know isn't good but
it's because I hate it when people who
are super emotional about everything
kind of vampirize my feelings I don't
want to do that to somebody else yeah I
get that too because like nobody wants
to hang around with the person that's
just like constantly whining about their
feelings right and it's like you don't
want to be that person
but on the other hand it's probably not
good to just like not talk about your
feelings ever either yeah you know what
I mean you gotta hit happy medium
all right so um
what's been going on
Dave is saying um I didn't know her I
saw your post about it earlier Dave like
um someone that used to go to
um I think it was a Visage named Carissa
she died yeah like
it's getting to that point you guys
where all your friends start down all
our yeah we're not even that old they're
young she died of some kind of a liver
infection or something that's [ __ ] up
what they said they were not sure
exactly why she died
something that had to do with their
liver
I mean in the past few years we've had
several
people in our scene diet and most of
them were young yeah cancer
it wasn't even like older people girls
basically which is crazy Kaylee I think
had just turned 30 huh 34 34. she looked
a lot younger though she did yeah she's
like a baby
she was maybe like four foot ten
wouldn't you say yeah she was a little
tiny little bitty thing yeah
yeah Dave said liver failure liver
failure yeah
I hadn't seen her in years though I
barely remember I hadn't either yeah
John Smith said I knew I was getting
older when the first childhood friend
died of natural causes right yeah that's
the thing
I mean like I said it's just it's weird
because
it's weird because like I said it's a
handful I don't know it's not a lot but
I mean several people like in our scene
that we knew died but almost all of them
were young like unusually young yeah Amy
Lee turned 40. I remember I just think
of her as a kid
oh I actually thought she was older than
that no she just turned 40. holy [ __ ]
she's younger than I am yeah that's
crazy yeah I was hanging out with my
siblings last Sunday at Downtown Disney
well it's not called Downtown Disney
anymore it's called Disney Springs but
it's the same thing and my brother who
is four years younger than me
informed me that his son Ethan who I
still remember as a four-year-old kid is
now 18. man
he told me that like we were sitting out
on uh at Trader Sam's and we were
sitting out having like cocktails and he
said something about that and I was like
and I just like
I just froze yeah
that's like Jen and Dimitri's daughter
holy [ __ ]
Jenna Dimitri's daughter was over at our
house she was like a 12 year old girl
yeah
like a kid then the next thing you knew
it she's hanging out the club with us
yeah she comes to the club with her
boyfriend she's like 19. she's like 19.
well and Jen has another daughter that's
22. yeah 22 23. you never know that they
were all like mother and daughter they
just look like a group of
cute women
they all you know they all look you know
they could just be a group of friends
really
well yeah like I said we've
met up before it just kind of seems like
everybody just kind of hangs out with
each other like regardless of yeah yeah
it's weird the Galaxy is [ __ ] weird
where
they're hanging out in these [ __ ]
wild ass clubs their parents are in
there and it's like not an issue
yeah I couldn't imagine that
yeah that would be really generational
differences or not that would be yeah
it's it's not the same yeah like yeah
that would be really weird like like and
my parents were actually like pretty
cool like they weren't you know super
like [ __ ] conservative or anything
like that but it would still be kind of
weird like going I don't think it would
be that weird well it would now but I
mean back in the day I don't think it
would have been weird going to a club
with my mom but I went to the bar with
my dad but that was a [ __ ] hockey
talk bar man country western [ __ ] I
couldn't and a lot of and a lot of dudes
go to like hang out and like drink with
their Dads that's not straight I
couldn't I couldn't imagine being in a
golf club had my dad there
I can't imagine your mom no
no that would be actually that [ __ ] I'm
kind of I'm kind of imagining it and
it's just kind of like making me
horrified my dad be like is that a boy
or a girl yeah that's what they would
all do that like old people [ __ ] yeah
they would be doing right [ __ ] like my
grandpa was doing like when he was
watching MTV in the 80s why is he
wearing eyeliner yeah you know that's
what my yeah he got why has he got black
fingernail polish yeah
I mean again
yeah like I said that's like what my
grandpa used to say like he didn't go to
clubs obviously but like when MTV you'd
be watching MTV in the 80s yeah and he
just had something to say about every
single thing that came on why are they
wearing earring they're all gay yeah
they're all on drugs
he would just like say all this stuff
like that and he was like he died in
1991 I think why is that guy wearing his
girlfriend's clothes
[Laughter]
like where have you guys been
that was going on back in there yeah
back in the 60s it's like when they were
like young so you think they'd be used
to it by now yeah I don't really know
why they're not
that's I don't know it was like [ __ ]
go look look at [ __ ] look at [ __ ]
look at the [ __ ] well what's his name
Robert Plant okay
those [ __ ] pants he had on they
didn't [ __ ] make guys pants another
[ __ ] cut
[ __ ] girls bell bottoms yeah
how's his girlfriend's pants well that's
what you had to do back then I mean
unless you knew how to make your own
[ __ ] yeah
um you know they didn't make men's pants
that were like fitted and velvet and all
that kind of stuff like yeah you had to
just buy a girlfriend yeah
God's [ __ ] in his girlfriend's pants
yeah yeah that's okay they looked good
Jimmy Page
oh [ __ ] pickled and [ __ ] [ __ ]
playing guitar I can't believe that that
dude [ __ ] still alive he's still
alive
with Jimmy Page I think he is I think
he's from pickled or formaldehyde or
something
yeah I'm gonna do this [ __ ]
constantly drunk
another one that was always [ __ ]
drunk was oh [ __ ]
do the same Like a Rolling Stone and
[ __ ] what was his name [ __ ] that sang
like a roller yeah yeah like a rolly
Bob Dylan yeah Bob for a second I
thought you were I saw [ __ ] Bob Dylan
Live this is back on I was still a kid
this is the very late 80s Bob Dylan was
live on the Letterman show David
Letterman show and he could barely
[ __ ] stand and he's obviously [ __ ]
up and David Letterman was joking about
it
the [ __ ] he was hammered
I guess he just walked around just
hammered
I can't imagine like I enjoy being drunk
as much as the next person but I don't
think I'd want to live my whole entire
life like that I think when you're Bob
Dylan you just you can just do whatever
you wanted well yeah that's true
maybe they figure hey if I just stay
drunk all the time I'll never be
hungover
oh there'll never be um accused of not
being able to sing because he asked me
Bob Dylan couldn't sing
well I don't know if it was so much
not he just had a distinctive singing
style that's all
you know go ahead and keep telling
yourself dad I don't think no I'm just
saying because well I can't really like
[ __ ] on Bob Dylan because you know I I
liked like a lot of punk and stuff like
that none of them could really sing
either but they had like a distinctive
kind of sound to them you know
you know singing folk music I guess it
was just from another generation
he was saying something to them that
they valued I didn't mind Bob Dylan I
couldn't really relate to what he was
talking about
stitchy stuff
I mean you know I guess it is a little
bit dated at some point but
only songs I remembered liking was like
uh All Along the Watchtower
and Like a Rolling Stone
so in Tucson's I knew from him
I've heard some other stuff but it was
just seemed to be like real forgettable
but yeah I I guess you just had to be
our parents generation to get into that
I guess it was kind of like Morrissey to
them
yeah I guess so
I guess so
um let's see oh El padrino oh remember
because El padrino was here on Wednesday
asking if we had done a show about
Jonestown and I said that we did so he
went and watched it okay uh yeah so
watched it Wednesday after the show you
know the creepiest moments for some
reason are after The Massacre someone
came in before the cleanup Cavalry how
are those bodies aligned up like that I
guess I don't know like I think they all
just kind of like laid around and they
knew what they were doing
oh he's talking about all the poisons
yeah no they had security guards
and I think they were uh
putting them in line to die or after
they did die [ __ ] would put him we're
lining them up
yeah you know they had security guards
and the security guards were telling
people what to do it was part of a
plan you know they knew it was coming
yeah they knew what they were doing yeah
they knew what they were doing
I mean
you know the kids probably didn't grasp
it but
and you could hear in audio recordings
all the kids crying in the background
I was I went and I was in um you're
making the kids drink the Kool-Aid yeah
I was in where the [ __ ] was I I was in
North Carolina or something like that
and I went to a theater because I was
like oh this sounds like a good time I'm
gonna go see a documentary about
Jonestown in a movie theater like an
indie movie house and holy [ __ ] that was
the most depressing thing I've ever seen
I didn't even realize until I saw that
documentary I can't remember what it was
called now but you can probably find it
it's pretty famous is I didn't realize
how much of the [ __ ] that happened at
Jonestown was recorded they recorded
everything yeah so like so much of the
last stuff it's just ugh like that all
that audio and [ __ ] Jim Jones used to
you know do his speeches and [ __ ] like
that over the over the intercom like all
the time it was [ __ ] up he was like he
was like uh
[ __ ] Marlon Brando from Ireland to Dr
Moreau he was that that character was
reminded me a lot of Jim Jones yeah he
did kind of now that you mentioned yeah
crazy Jim Jones well Jim Jones was
[ __ ] crazy
uh what's even crazier is that those
people did what he said this goes to
show you eat the people that are easy to
brainwash
I guess you just have to uh get them all
together and
tell them what they want to hear and
you got to get an US versus them
mentality going and
over time sleep deprivation and
discipline
over time you can get them to believe
anything and even then some of them
didn't buy into it and we're trying to
get the [ __ ] out of there yeah you know
what I mean so it wasn't everybody that
fell for it and I think that like a lot
of machine gun yeah that's what I mean
they wanted to leave yep uh grafter says
question where did uh Kirsty alley Soul
go when she passed from this Earth being
a thetan
for feet and eight what does that has to
mean something of that absolutely yeah
she was the operating thing she dropped
her body I guess she uh
she uh she moved on uh whoa [ __ ] what
was what did they call it
she just
because she's not in the volcano
yeah I'm not real clear
that's bad right yeah okay okay yeah
that's that's where all the [ __ ] body
thetans were oh
low-level alien criminals because of
course they were all in the volcano yeah
they had them trapped in a volcano and
then Xenu dropped atomic bombs on the
volcano to destroy him
but that just blew them out everywhere
that just you know
spread them I mean obviously yeah
that was gonna happen I'll tell you what
man
I wish I could help I wish I could pull
some [ __ ] out of my ass like that and
like make a billion dollars that'd be
awesome Albert had quite the imagination
he was quite a [ __ ] storytell
I gotta hand it to Hubbard though
the cult liked him
and out of cult leaders he was like one
of the better ones uh he wasn't
sexually uh abusing uh women which or
men a lot of them are views in men too
but he wasn't abusing anybody he was
actually pretty
sexually conservative I guess you could
say
um
he was just just he was just lying you
know he was lying and he wasn't he
wasn't much of a family man
um
didn't care much about his family or his
kids but you know he thought children
were adults and they weren't really
directly related to you they had their
own Destinies and stuff he had his own
way of [ __ ] looking at things
yeah uh that's one way of putting it
they were reincarnated from other people
they didn't really have anything to do
to you do with you in his mind you were
just a vessel yeah
vessel for these alien Souls
man I got all kind of alien Souls yeah
[Laughter]
he'd get up on the free winds and hide
out he's afraid the feds are looking for
him
with his little teenage [ __ ] cabin
girls running around being Messengers
what were they called Captain's
Messengers I think right I don't know
he'd have them in a little shorty shorts
running around
and um
he'd tell them stories be up on the deck
tell them stories in the middle of the
night
underneath the Stars
and uh they said that's when the cult
was good you know they they liked that
and um so
out of the cult leaders he was actually
kind of one of the good ones
if there is such a thing as a good cult
leader yeah yeah I would argue no yeah
it's a spectrum kind of sort of
dispatcher he was one of the good ones
though
he wasn't very abusive
um
he's just more of a con man
you know he's gone man although I don't
know
because he died trying to summon alien
souls and talking to alien Souls that he
was [ __ ] crazy
so he he did and in the end I think buy
his own [ __ ]
I think yeah yeah well maybe that
happens if you just like pretend long
enough you just kind of like [ __ ]
well he's making up all these stories
and realities bending to his will and
then all of a sudden he's got an Empire
and running a company that's worth
millions tens of millions of dollars and
he's making a secret secret Scientology
bases and he's got a ship and he kind of
came from nothing you know
so maybe you start to believe your own
[ __ ] well of course this is true or
none of this would have happened
yeah yeah I think that happens to a lot
of people I think that's what happened
so then he's trying to uh commune with
alien souls and teeth falling out and
taking drugs and
no I forgot what he was on and
he was just kind of an old [ __ ] up
looking Colonel Sanders [ __ ]
at the end of his life just died in
obscurity
you know and like I don't remember if it
was a trailer or just a real shitty
house out in the middle of the desert
with uh surrounded by suitcases full of
cash they'd bring him suitcases of cash
that was like his fugitive money in case
he had to run he couldn't carry all them
[ __ ] hey at least it wasn't jars of
urine and fingernail clipping yeah
Howard Hughes and then uh when he died
when he died mysteriously David
miscavige ended up being in charge of
everything
and uh
fired all the other heads of the church
so he so he was next in line he took
over
because you got the drop on everybody
Miss cabbage
and
there's rumors that that money kind of
disappeared they don't know what
happened to all that money so yeah I
wonder I wonder yeah where it might have
gone Miss gavage probably got all that
I wouldn't put it past miscavige to have
allegedly
um
done something to directly cause
death remember remember Chris what's his
name um Chris Sheldon yeah that
I talked like if they thought allegedly
allegedly yeah one of them one of the
Scientology guys that left Scientology
he had his own channel for a while I
talked to him online
it was direct messaging him but before
he got kind of famous and then he ended
up losing his channel
and I asked Chris about that that if he
thought that Miss cabbage maybe had
something to do with the death of L Ron
Hubbard at the end of Hubbard's life
when he was getting weak and kind of
crazy
and she and and Sheldon said no I don't
think he said he didn't think so he said
that as far as he could tell Miss
cabbage um
was had a lot of fear and respect for L
Ron Hubbard that he was feared and
respected him but he did think that
after he died that [ __ ] miscavage was
scooped in there and
took over real quick fired a bunch of
people accused people of being
basically suppressive persons or SPS had
people locked up inside the religious
prisons and
did everything he could in a period of
like just a couple of days to inherit
the throne
and he took over and what was funny Miss
cabbage was at the time that he did that
was basically a high-ranking kid in the
church he didn't know much about
scientology he just knew
about the Scientology machine the
organization you know the you the way
the unit was structured he knew all
about that but he didn't know anything
about too much about
Scientology as a religion you know he
didn't he didn't he didn't study L Ron
Hubbard's works all that much
he just knew that
he knew the ins and outs of the
institution he knew how to get what he
needed to he knew how to get whatever he
wanted done and inside the rules of that
institution it'd be like saying
dude is a master at [ __ ] uh paperwork
in the Army and [ __ ] filling out
forms to get [ __ ] done but he's not a
very good soldier he just knows how to
[ __ ] manipulate his way through the
through the Army system you know that's
kind of the way L Ron Hubbard was they
had dudes in the army that were like
that
El padrino says after watching uh your
other videos I enjoy both of your senses
of humor well thank you very much thanks
yeah uh also Zach says I always used to
get Kirsty alley and Kathleen Turner
confused with each other I don't know
how that could happen because Katherine
Turner is like way hotter yeah sorry
Kirstie Alley was cute when she was
young she was but I still think Kathleen
Turner was way hotter and way sexier she
was real uh she was cute in um the old
Star Trek movies remember when she
played what was her name [ __ ]
saval or no what was it she played the
Vulcan yeah the Vulcan girl I can't
remember
I mean Kathleen Turner actually I think
one of my favorite roles of hers was in
uh the Man with Two Brains
where she was like the evil yeah At
first she was like [ __ ] Steve
Martin's like evil wife she was [ __ ]
hilarious in that [ __ ]
what are those [ __ ] doing on the
porch I love that [ __ ] movie if you
guys haven't seen what the Man with Two
Brains please please go see the man with
super Brains it's Steve Martin Kathleen
Turner and David Warner it's [ __ ]
hysterical it's one of my favorite
movies from the 80s
uh let's see they're talking about I got
way behind granter said uh Kirsty was
hot in Star Trek 2 Wrath of Khan yeah
yeah young gramster had special time
with a bar of soap in the shower after
watching that oh [ __ ]
well you know what was the name of that
character
Oh I thought wasn't there a K in it and
a v
or something yeah something like that
I don't remember
you're talking about Tom Cruise and
David miscavage your special friends
yeah
um
I I need to get back into the
scientologists all the Scientology uh uh
Gossip
um the one that was the real good giving
up information was um
uh the guy who the squirrel Busters was
attacking what was his [ __ ] name um
Marty Rathbun
he was a Scientologist that left the
church but he believed in Scientology he
was teaching it to people for free
they were standing on these sending
these things called squirrel Busters who
were these scientologists with cameras
[ __ ] come up beating on his doors
that's her name I knew there was a k and
a v yeah
I thought it was saval but savic yeah
anyway uh
um what was I talking about I was
talking about okay
Marty
used to have a whole bunch of videos up
on YouTube this was back like 2009
2010 around that time
and I watched everything he put out he
put out some [ __ ] real interesting
really interesting details about the
church
one uh um render Mike render tells good
stories about the church too he's
probably still on YouTube
well he's on he's on uh what's her name
show too yeah
Leah Remini Leah Remini yeah he's on
there all the time
but um
according to I think I think it was uh
Marty
who tells this
now I don't know if if this is [ __ ]
Scientologist playing games trying to
get them to turn on each other
but
according to Marty Rathbun
Tom Cruise and uh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] man [ __ ]
[ __ ] what's the uh
what's the head what's cob's name
[ __ ] I forgot it's not too much of
cob chairman of the board
um
the guy who runs Scientology I was just
been saying his name David
Miss cabbage likes Tom Cruise when Tom
Cruise is around and as soon as Tom
Cruise turns his back
[ __ ] he starts [ __ ] talking about
Tom Cruise like he's a douche like man
dude's a [ __ ] tool you know like Miss
cabbage we can talk yeah
but they would go out and ride
motorcycles and [ __ ] together and what
was going on with those two is that
they're both short guys so they're kind
of like in the short guy Mafia when
you're short you tend to fall in with
other short guys and it's kind of like
little people like midgets midgets
[ __ ] sometimes they want to be the
only [ __ ] well it's kind of like that
with the short guys too so they want to
be the only short dude around
but uh
yeah there's uh
they're kind of Frenemies I think but I
got a feeling that Tom
that Tom takes takes [ __ ] miss gavage
real seriously you know but I don't
think miscavage takes time them two are
like 14 year old girls yeah they're like
14 year olds actually no I that's an
insult to 14 year old girls right
um 14 year old girls are a lot more
mature than that yeah and I'm under the
impression based on the whole
of at least the way it was I don't know
if it's like this right now but the way
it was at least you know 10 15 20 years
ago
miscavige and Tom Cruise kind of ran
Scientology on a social level like they
walked around like they were [ __ ]
high-ranking generals and of an army you
know that it was like their religion
that they were they were running it
because they could have whatever they
wanted in there tomka should show up
with his new SUV and just pull up in
some [ __ ]
shop that Scientology had control of and
he'd go yeah I want an all new interior
and custom GPS [ __ ] lecd screens I
want [ __ ] and and a bunch of
scientologists to get in there and
totally rebuild the inside of his car do
a custom interior on it and not pay a
[ __ ] dime it would just be yeah
Church expenses
imagine that
because it's all now part of it it's the
church you know it's a church vehicle
[Laughter]
I want a satellite link on it and
everything you know I can't imagine I
can't imagine being that much of an
entitled douchebag where you could just
like walk in anywhere and get whatever
you want yeah get whatever you want and
everyone just like fall yes sir yes sir
looks like the military that'd be really
really like the military and it's got
its own unlimited Church budget so you
can just use all of its facilities
and uh you know they had whole complexes
making made for Tom and his girlfriends
or his wives you know
tennis courts and [ __ ] [ __ ] with
flowers and
Bungalows and places where they could go
have walks and [ __ ]
to make a [ __ ] Paradise on Earth for
Tom and
uh [ __ ] his wife which wife was it it
was the it was the blood the one that
was in Moulin Rouge what was her [ __ ]
name Nicole Kidman she's actually a
redhead More Than a Woman okay yeah
Nicole I mean I kind of feel like she's
one they built a whole [ __ ]
basis behind Tom Cruise and Nicole
Kidman they're trying to get her in the
church and she shot she thought that
[ __ ] was too weird she eventually
[ __ ] split
see that's I have a lot more respect for
that she's like no no yeah well she
doesn't she had her own [ __ ] she had
[ __ ] you money she didn't need anything
to do with it well that's what I mean
she didn't need anything she's like I'm
already famous [ __ ] I don't need you
people they're trying to get her to go
through [ __ ] auditing and [ __ ]
give up all her secrets and [ __ ]
recorded so he can get dirt on her and
[ __ ] you know yeah I don't think so
I don't think so like I said she don't
got to do that [ __ ] I can see how maybe
like some actors that
you know aren't famous and they want to
get famous yeah because I don't really
know I do kind of feel like oh some
actors say that it helped them but I
don't know really what happened
Scientology yeah I know like when they
were when they were starting out yeah
when they were bombs but we never bombs
working at [ __ ] working at Denny's
and [ __ ] maybe it still [ __ ] blows my
mind that Elizabeth Monson is a [ __ ]
Scientologist because she's like a
[ __ ] amazing actor was she born in it
um she might have been now that I think
about it so that's that's different you
know what I mean that's different
because you don't like know any
different
El padrino said also I'm working on that
Billy D Williams Colt 45 works every
time five foot cardboard I need to see
if I get it so we can put it next time
that would be so awesome it was that
Billy D Williams back there with the
[ __ ] cold party every time I she did
every time I see David Parker open
mannequins [ __ ] club we go too he's
showing up with his [ __ ] Colt 45
and I said man did you start buying Colt
45 because I talked about it because no
I always drink this look at it like all
right
yeah it's pretty good
pretty good I mean if you if if you you
know if you're gonna just gonna try to
buy a beer at Circle K
you're not gonna get a big selection you
know the best thing in terms of taste
dollar for dollar out of Circle K beef
cult 45. the high gravity the black one
was good too it's kind of like a kind of
a little bit more like a stout or a you
know like a dark beer high gravity is
what they called it
[ __ ] they're talking about
high gravity everyone's like yeah I'm
pretty high right now I grab gravity I'm
floating about like it's got a
gravitational pull on you it does yeah
you put it on a shelf like that and you
start falling towards it slightly sucks
you toward it yeah and suck your mouth
onto it like that that's gross
[Laughter]
High Gravity
what the [ __ ] they're talking about we
need to get back into drinking stuff
doing the doing the taste test and like
get weird [ __ ] I'm gonna get back down
to the redneck store we were talking
about enchiladas that I got I thought
were gonna be nasty were [ __ ] good
man Modelo was [ __ ] great medella
that's kind of the problem that we were
having is like we bought some stuff that
like everybody's like we bought is like
it was supposed to be a joke but then we
drank it we're like well this is
actually bad
I've had I've I've actually thought
about [ __ ] stopping off to [ __ ]
getting some more of that [ __ ] Modelo
michelada I like that damn chilly one
yeah it was good the chili mango
wasn't it I think what was the one I
like the pineapple one the best but they
were all pretty good
we were talking I was talking to my
siblings on Sunday
and they were talking about that
remember that moonshine we bought that
was like apple pie and then we had one
that was like butter pecan yeah and we
went down to the other liquor store like
because we first saw them at the big uh
ABC liquor but then we went to this
little liquor store that's right down
here by republics like a mile away and
they had a couple other flavors yeah
they had like strawberries and cream
cherry maraschino cherries maraschino
cherries they had a pickle one pickle
yeah but my sister told me she's like
it's old smokey or whatever I think it's
called ultimate it's a Tennessee like
moonshine company she's like they have a
coffee Mocha one for and she's like it's
really good they have like a whole bunch
of other flavors because she's had that
one too but she'd had the apple pie one
and she had the butter pecan one she's
like they're all good but she's like
there's a coffee Mocha one so if you can
find that one get it because it's really
really good the only problem is they're
expensive they are very expensive one
jars 20 bucks yeah it's like yeah it's
like 19 yeah it's like 18.99 like for
one jar I mean it's a jar like that well
it's like it's about like this it's
about that size yeah
but or like a mason jar size yeah the
Cherry one is just filled with
maraschino cherries it's just like salad
cherries
yeah
imagine there's a [ __ ] ton of calories
in that you're sitting there drinking
that [ __ ] oh yeah but cherries the other
one's got a bunch of pickles in it yeah
I might try again I might dig that I
listen I love pickles yeah but you know
what I mean
um I can make that myself probably well
yeah that's the thing go down here and
make some moonshine get me a still going
but I mean that would cost significantly
more than 18.99 well now once the
Steel's up you know well yeah
yeah speaking of calories
um if you guys know I guess I didn't
know about this place because but
apparently it's like really famous so I
was
um at Disney Springs on Sunday and there
is a Cookie Shop there called Gideon's
bake house and the ins it's small but
like the inside of it is like it kind of
looks like Tim Burton me like it looks
like a Tim Burton Library kind of thing
it's really cool inside
um I got there and my sister my brothers
were like sorry Pookie come here it was
an accident she's like hey kicked her in
the face my sister and my brothers had
been there since like 10 30 or 11 30 in
the morning and they said oh well we put
in a a virtual line thing because
apparently this Cookie Shop is so
popular that people will wait in line
for like hours and hours and hours just
to get like a cookie and some coffee
from there that's all they do is cookies
cake and coffee
they don't have that much stuff
and so like I gotta tell my story here
in a minute okay well can I tell a story
because you've been you're gonna love
this [ __ ] but yeah I didn't tell you yet
oh okay oh okay oh it's a news story
yeah but yeah so they so they had put in
like virtual line because that's the
thing my sister and my brother are like
really really into Disney so they know
all the little hacks and whatnot
so we get there we get in line we get in
we get the cookies and I got one it was
called a Kris Kringle these cookies dude
they're like six dollars each but
they're like half a pound I mean they're
massive and I got this one that it was
like all like white chocolate and there
was like coffee in there oh my God it
was like [ __ ] amazing I couldn't eat
the whole thing like I just ate little
bits of it all day and they have like
really good like um cold brew and [ __ ]
like that when we left
the place they said the line at that
point was five hours long people were
waiting five hours to get in there and
get a [ __ ] cookie yeah no thank you I
mean the cookies are good no but I'm
just saying but okay they will tell you
how I [ __ ] up last night I didn't say
anything
yesterday throughout the day I was doing
stuff like going down and making
um
dough for um
pumpkin pie crust
so I made the doughs baked baked the
crusts and everything
then I went down there to go and I had
that sugar pumpkin
slurry and I made enough for two of the
pies
and I poured the pies in there baked
them
then last night before I went to bed
went down there and pulled the pies out
when they were done put those pies up to
cool
woke up this morning went down there to
get a slice of that pie
got a big old Nice Slice of panic so
that didn't rise too much kind of funny
color it's a ate it texture was okay and
also said oh I spit it out I forgot to
put the [ __ ]
forgot to put the [ __ ] um
[ __ ] um condensed milk in there
yeah
no sugar at all
not in a condensed milk what am I
thinking of I don't know
yeah condensed milk I think it's good
condensed milk yeah it could not
evaporated milk condensed milk I forgot
to put it in there
so I I had to I threw two pies away
I wondered what had happened to those
because you said about making them last
night and I forgot I forgot to put that
in a slurry
well yeah wasted it yeah I got a lot of
that pie I got a lot of that uh pumpkin
you're gonna make another one later yeah
I'll make more later I mean I could do
some pumpkin pie right now yeah I'll do
it tomorrow
I'll be too drunk after the show yeah
I [ __ ] throw two pies out really but
you know what though at least I didn't
lose the condensed milk because that's
the most expensive ingredient in there
yeah I got a lot of the pumpkin
and the uh the pie crust was nothing
just the pie crust itself I just used
the old trick of
all-purpose flour and mayonnaise yeah
to make it and then pressed it down in
there and then put another pie plate on
top there for weight yeah that works out
really good yeah two ingredients because
it's the same as Sam is using you know
oil and egg yolks you know that'll
that'll be good that'll do that'll do it
but I was like it was so close there's
just no
no sweet in it at all just [ __ ] I was
going to man I wonder if I could pull
this filling out and do something else
with it
maybe pick a [ __ ] Curry or something
I was like ah it's only two cups I
[ __ ] threw that [ __ ] away you know
oh well yeah
four cups you didn't tell me that yeah
yeah yeah I was embarrassed about this
[ __ ]
not embarrassed enough to like tell the
entire YouTube I'm drunk now oh okay
Samuel Grime says oh my God first live
stream I've caught for absolutely ages
and my kitty cat Paul yeah your cat's
name is Paul that's okay got out of the
back door while I went for a smoke
luckily I've got him now oh I was gonna
say geez don't scare me like that uh
Anthony said opinion on Wednesday the
gugu muck dance now see I know that
that's we haven't got to that episode
yet but I already knew that was coming
because my sister told me about it that
she's gonna do like a dance to a um
Korean song so she's like well I didn't
want to spoil it for you but I just
wanted to tell you we gotta start
plugging the show more we need we didn't
even get uh to uh commercials last
episode that's why we don't make any
money
we don't [ __ ] sell anything
well you know we don't [ __ ] sell
books
well you know we sell books it's just we
don't plug books you know
Jenny just likes to get on here and talk
I was like Jenny man [ __ ] play the
commercial now I play of course
what time is it
seven okay
I played one at the end where hour in
yeah everybody's checking out by then
though checking off that sounds nasty
didn't it yeah I'm checking off yeah I'm
checking out I bet you are checking out
I'll bet you are
El padrino
well then it wouldn't really beat you
well I don't know I guess it's so
nothing better
um El padrino said I'm assuming that
you're talking to us guys I don't even
know your names I just came here out of
nowhere what's your name wait are you
talking to us or are you talking to like
other people
I'm Tom he's Tom yeah obviously yeah
yeah
obviously yeah Tom and Jenny like kind
of kind of like Tom and Jerry yeah
that's a lot of people say that
uh Graveler said you could have made uh
Crow meat pies with those Crush you know
shoot a couple crows in the backyard mix
up the meats and Bon Appetit Bon Appetit
and then Cheryl said wasted pie what a
sad story see I didn't even know about
that like I knew that he was thinking
about making them because he went down
and like made slurry I just went down
there and grabbed them [ __ ] pies and
then today I was thinking about I was
like oh thank you very much thank you
camp guys peace loved it thank you very
much and I was like whatever happened to
those pumpkin pies so now I now I had to
throw them out forgot to put the
condensed milk in them man
they would have been good too
they'd have been really good
well I guess we'll never know I'll make
them again
[Laughter]
he's had my pie
that also sounded dirty everything you
say sounds adorable that's something a
girl would say you had my pie so I guess
I got the cream on it and everything
yeah yeah he sent us the money baby
thank you Graham if you were supported
just like NPR yes
we're like public television we're doing
a pledge Drive
uh Sebastian Moran said the books are on
Amazon I don't know who they come from
though uh plug the t-shirts great
quality yeah
um yeah we always have shirts like we I
have like a Zazzle store where I have
some shirts on there but we also do some
designs that we screen print ourselves
but yeah the books are from Amazon like
I publish them myself so
they just come from Amazon they print
them and that's kind of their thing
I do my own audio books also
and let's see
he's Tom LOL
Oscar says what that was your big story
Tom well I mean I thought it was a very
sad story because I had wondered about
what happened to those [ __ ] pies you
know
he brings stuff up and then like forgets
about it and I'm just kind of like hey
hey whatever happened to that
because he doesn't tell me a lot of
stuff he's like sneaky like that going
around down there and like throw a box
away
ah Cheryl said my dog would have loved
those pies yeah maybe we should have fed
him to Pokey she I don't know man like
Pokey is not real into like people food
Beijing isn't either now that I think
about it
the only thing oh you know what Pokey
likes she likes
um
whipped cream like if you have a piece
of pie or something like that that has
whipped cream on it she'll just like
come and be like oh oh she'll stick her
little nose in there it's like can I
have some
other than that she's mostly like cap oh
you know what she does like I do have
like these little kind of um in my
office I have these little snack
uh things of like um what do you call
them like shrimp noodles
with all those ramen noodles yeah and um
if on the on the occasions like the rare
occasions when I heat one of those up
and eat it oh she's all about that
because it's shrimpy smelling so she's
just like jumps into the zapper Pookie
and I'm just like nope right not
she's like can I have some though
what's up Polk
would you have eaten a pumpkin pie that
Daddy messed up no
okay this is
fresh squeezed lemonade from the lemons
out and back oh okay let's see how this
is they're a little Milder
yeah that's nice actually
it is mild but that's okay yeah Oscar
says uh Jenny can you review those
across the river by Christopher buellman
on tones of Terror um I'll get to it
eventually I have a bunch of actually I
got behind because I didn't get to do a
book the book that I was supposed to do
last week because I didn't finish
reading it so I'm actually gonna like
push it up to this week thank you Dom
the bomb I've not been around for a
while but Tom is starting to look like a
rip to Ming the merciless yeah thank you
yeah I was actually thinking of Ming
when I did that [ __ ] yeah pretty big man
see
that
get in there
I'm gonna try to put on another 10
pounds
um but yeah oh what I was saying was I
had an author that sent me a couple of
books to link for free so I'm gonna
review those like over the next couple
weeks also but I will probably get I did
start reading one book not that one but
I did start reading one book by
Christopher bielman and I couldn't
really get into it but maybe they're not
all like that so I'll give that one a
whirl
John Smith said my cats are into people
food uh one will try and convince people
she's being starved
she's a liar from her heart-shaped nose
to her Jelly Bean toes yeah that's um
what Pookie does is she basically she
has little food stations like all around
the house you know and she's just kind
of like I'll give her a meat stick in
the room like when Tom's not in there
and then as soon as Tom comes back in
the room she'll be like Daddy I don't
I'm I would really like a meat stick
again I'm like you just had one
she'll just eat them all day long she's
got this thing where she'll climb up on
my chest like that and then put her paws
up right up here and she'll she'll look
at me look at my face like that and go
and she'll try to get her
nose underneath my hands because
sometimes I fall asleep with my hands up
on my chest like that she tries to get
her head underneath here just try to do
that to you sometimes put her head
underneath your hand well if it and
sometimes even if your hands are on the
sides like like sometimes I'll be
sleeping like that with my hand on the
side and I feel a little fuzzy head
going yeah yeah she's like trying to
like try to get underneath yeah
underneath your head so you can pet her
yeah
she crazy
um let's see Danny rolling said the
Canadian 1981 Subterranean flick the
boogens yeah I've heard of that I think
I might have seen it but it was a long
time ago would make a good winter time
review because it's set in the snow
filthy Gardener said you looked hardcore
who filthy Gardener said that so yeah I
looked said yeah oh thank you very much
well I don't look hardcore do I
um El pedrina said nice job on the
Philadelphia Experiment episode yeah
that's been a while
Oscar says the authors that send you
their books tend to be bad no offense to
them
yeah I mean you know I don't know well
people try to plug their own material
you know what I mean they're a lot of
you got people who are new writers you
know what I mean yeah you know
[ __ ] you have great bands they're for
their demo albums aren't that good you
know what I mean it's gonna be [ __ ] like
that
but you know later on you know some of
them might be end up being good
yeah and I mean some of the books
actually some of the books that I've
been sent were actually really good some
of them not so much but you know what I
mean it's just kind of like I don't know
I just kind of feel like I wouldn't send
my books to people to like review them
you know
um I think you did a long time ago
didn't you
didn't we
we actually said we did not didn't we
gave out uh Mountain Poltergeist
to a couple people
yeah
that's not really a novel though no
that's what I mean I was more talking
about that yeah I'm talking about a
novel yeah you do a novel but math Matt
we gave we gave a few a couple of free
uh we gave out a couple fragments of
people the only time I did that was one
time I sent a copy of one of my short
story collections to Gothic Beauty the
magazine and they reviewed it they give
me like a half page oh really so that
was pretty awesome that's cool but they
like they liked it though I'm always
kind of like scared that like I'm kind
of scared to set myself out I probably
shouldn't be because
some of the stuff I've read that you
know I'm not like [ __ ] on people
across the board but
um you know and I'm not [ __ ] on
self-published authors because I publish
my own [ __ ] too because you know
because I'm a control freak and I like
to do my own coppers and I like to do my
layouts and [ __ ] like that
but
um I kind of feel like a lot of books
actually not even books that are
self-published because I've gotten books
from Publishers Publishers that had an
alarming amount of grammatical and
spelling errors in there and I know that
I'm like a stickler about it but still
it's like something that an editor
should have fixed
um Jeffy Art thank you very much Jenny
do you have anything on Amazon audible
or Kindle yes uh all of my stuff is on
Amazon just search Jenny Ashford like
you know uh whatever it is like um what
do they call that the odd just author
page I think
I have
um
most of my stuff is on audiobook
and I mean obviously I did print
versions I think I have ebook versions
of everything and I think I have
audiobook versions of most things I
think a couple of my novels maybe I
don't but I think because I just never
got around to it because they were older
but all of my non-fiction I have audio
versions of and all of my almost all of
my um short story collections I have
audio versions of that too but yeah it's
all on there all my stuff
all my stuff is on there
um what's a topic you'd like to see a
horror movie cover
um I don't know I have to think about
that I'll I'll put a pin in that and
come back Oscar said Jenny have you
written any horror fiction yes I have
written two books of short stories
and three novels three novels some yeah
I think three novels I wanna I've got
like about a quarter of another one
written but I just haven't had time to
like work on it unfortunately you know
what I mean here's the mask all right
I'm gonna run to the bathroom real quick
commercials Why Oh I thought you were
showing them yeah yeah
all right yeah we got to get commercials
in this [ __ ] too
this is the man
it's actually not bad it's just that
it's not
quite big enough
it needs a little bit more room I think
but I think it'll uh
I think it'll turn out okay
if you start yelling your jaw
will pop out through the bottom there's
a little bit too much space in the back
so it has to be range and if Pookie's
looking at me like what the [ __ ]
but I think it'll make a good Bane
costume once I'm done
and I get to get the voice down
all right
Harvey Dent
[Laughter]
victory has weakened you
but I may
but you see see that right there
looks too much like a toy I'm gonna age
that
get that color aged aged a little bit up
in here
that's actually looks pretty close to
the movies it's just the sizing
now on the movie version it opens here
and it's a flaps on both sides that's
how he gets it on and off and I think
I'm going to cut that and add leather to
either side and then use velcro in there
so I can get a little bit more size out
of it it's a little bit too small
all right
let's see oh
uh did you guys review The Kristen
Stewart film underwater yet yes we did
actually we really liked that movie you
bought it didn't you what's that
underwater the ones oh yeah yeah yeah
underwater I own it yeah yeah that's
what I thought
that's what I thought
oh they seemed like it
yeah like I thought it looked good yeah
to be honest
Zach asked what
um
what I would want to see covered like in
a horror movie that I guess hasn't been
that's a hard question actually
I don't know I still can't think of
anything
I still can't think of anything
yeah John Smith said I liked underwater
Kristen Stewart is unfairly maligned
yeah I think I kind of feel bad for her
because of you know she kind of came to
fame
in Twilight same with Robert Pattinson
and both of them are like completely
good actors but they just got associated
with that franchise
so
what are you gonna do yeah I thought
underwater was great we saw it in the in
the theater I think twice didn't we yeah
I think we saw it too James and um it
held up and then I bought it I think
it's a great movie it's
kind of like uh
kind of like something about an alien
but it's [ __ ] Cthulhu I I thought it
was [ __ ] great you know yeah and it's
kind of like something out of
out of Ridley Scott's future I liked it
grafter says is whale on your movie list
I do want to see it yeah it's Darren
Aronofsky uh you know same guy that did
Noah you know about a 600 pound man
Brendan Frazier is getting Oscar talking
yeah I've heard about that uh I actually
do want to see that yeah I'll get around
to it I think Danny was saying that that
version of Bane wasn't as Jack the other
version was better I have the the
[ __ ] the Mexican or the South
American version too I got that
I got the uh the luchadora mask and
there's a couple different versions you
can do with that one but I was that one
last Halloween
Tom Hardy's bang was good I liked it uh
he was a little overweight in it
if you ask me he looks a little soft
but he did a good job I mean you know it
didn't he didn't Tom Hardy's not a big
dude okay you should have seen him when
he was young he was a little cutie
really he was like basically you're
talking about somebody like River
Phoenix that's how he started you know
he got big for
for who he was he was a little actor you
know
he was kind of like a little teen actor
when he started so you know I'm [ __ ]
Tom Hardy did a good job for that role
he didn't have a lot a lot of time to to
get ready for it
he's obviously swollen up on Deanna ball
which will make you retain a lot of
water it'll make you look like the
Michelin Man because he's kind of pudgy
looking in it
because he's trying to get as big as he
possibly can he's looking at those damn
cartoons [ __ ] going how the hell am I
going to get that big and the amount of
time that he has
so
he's physically a taller guy than me
it's a it's harder to fill out a frame
that size
but I'm already a little bit bigger than
him in terms of [ __ ] definition
inside my proportions are bigger than he
is
uh in that movie
but I can still top it I got a year to
get ready for that costume I'm gonna try
to put on another five pounds of muscle
it's gonna look real good when I'm done
and I'm gonna see
I'm either gonna try to get build that
vest I don't think I want to buy the one
that they're selling the 75 one it just
doesn't look that good
to me
um
I might just go shirtless depending on
how good I look [ __ ] at the end of
the year
because he went shirtless in a couple
scenes just had his gauntlets on
our you know I ain't gonna [ __ ] brag
but his [ __ ] waist was looking worse
than mine really he was hiding it with
two belts
but if I'm looking really good by next
Halloween I'll just go shirtless
have Jenny shave my back
can't wait
Ben said didn't he do porn who
uh Tom Hardy I'm assuming he should have
Tammy said Hardy started out as a model
yeah he first got very big in Bronson
Bronson's a great movie but yeah great
movie yeah I got a lot of respect for
Tom Hardy as an actor oh he
for a dude who is not a bodybuilder he's
not a trained soldier
he's a model okay he started off as like
River Phoenix or who was the kid who
would [ __ ] Macaulay cough they could
do from [ __ ] Home Alone he was like
that when you first saw him and he got
big in [ __ ] Macho looking
in a pretty short period of time and I
think he's a he's a great actor for his
his
for his segment and his segment is
action
for a action star he's [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] Orson Welles for an action
star I mean he can act most action guys
can't really act he can act
he's the Dustin Hoffman of action Stars
and I can't believe he's not [ __ ]
James Bond
I'm trying to punch a [ __ ] now
why is he not James Bond
how am I how am I supposed to how can
you not make
okay he's British
that's his [ __ ] game you know what I
mean and
he could be a great James Bond
you know and and I like Craig I was a
Craig fan
I was a Dalton fan too you know but
especially the first movie but uh
I can't believe that they passed him up
for [ __ ] James Bond
although maybe he didn't want it maybe
no he wanted it he wanted it well I
don't know maybe they're lying maybe he
maybe they accepted him I'm hoping that
they're lying they said that he didn't
get it
Zach said Hardy used to post a lot of
nudes to Myspace back in the day
apparently and it looks like all the fat
in his body went to his ass and I mean
he has booty that man
a little drooly little thing
uh
I got that problem right now I'm doing I
got that [ __ ] thing called a land
mine you put the end of the end of your
uh Olympic Bar in it you put weights on
one side you do squats with it's a safe
way to do it squats because I got the
ass
Jenny says well you got a cute little
bubble butt
I'm trying to build up the back side of
my thighs and my ass the quads are doing
good I got [ __ ] fantastic
[ __ ] um
calf genetics my calves are better than
most [ __ ] ifbb Pros
look like two [ __ ] rotisserie
chickens back there like two little
babies asses on the [ __ ] back of my
thighs they're just [ __ ] they're
v-cut and everything [ __ ] real real
good leg genetics but I gotta bring it
out
so I'm working on that right there
because you got to keep the proportions
right you just can't keep piling muscle
on the [ __ ]
upper body and not
get thigh development quads [ __ ] uh
glutes you gotta get you know that's ass
glutes okay you gotta have that or
you're gonna look [ __ ] funny
hear them
it's got to be uniform
you get that
thick
manly look
ask Zach he knows all about them thick
manly look and that right Zach
see
taken mainly yeah
Oscar says he's too short to be Bond
it doesn't matter
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Craig wasn't all that tall I
think he's probably about the same size
as Craig probably
he's all right James Bond didn't have to
be cut tall because
in the books he and he wasn't even that
good looking in the books and he was
kind of beat up looking and he was drunk
all the time they had to pull him out of
the gutter in between missions and [ __ ]
Craig was a pretty close to the way he
was described in the books other than
the fact that he was blonde though and
in the books he was dark-haired
but uh I think I think [ __ ] if you
look at Hardy's work okay
and the other roles that he's played he
could easily play Bond
yeah I think he'd be good yeah no
problem
I mean he played both Craig Brothers
[ __ ]
convincingly Reggie and Ron he did them
both yeah well they were twins they were
twins but he did them both yeah but it
[ __ ] the gay one though was [ __ ]
he was heavier set it's almost kind of
like he'd gained 20 pounds in between
you notice that yeah every time they
showed him
Zach if you haven't seen that what was
the name of that movie it's called
Legend wouldn't it
yeah wasn't it Legends I think about
right yeah
I mean there's been more than one movie
about them yeah it's like you know what
I mean yeah I think it was called legend
Legends or something that was really
good I liked it fantastic British
gangster movie
I mean that's a whole British gangster
movies that's like a whole sub-genre on
doing stuff you'd probably dig a lot of
those actually actually Daniel Craig was
in a couple of them before he got super
famous
but um
Bond bond from the Fleming novels was
not described as some kind of model you
know you're not talking about Roger
Moore that's not what he was just you
described fancy lad no he wouldn't
he was an X SAS [ __ ]
Soldier and he was
stocky and his face was beat up like
from a bunch of [ __ ] fist fights
he had he could clean up and
wear a suit and [ __ ] he had a good
taste in things but
that's not who he was he was kind of
from the hood I guess you could say
uh but he was in a [ __ ] operative
he's a special operative glorified
[ __ ] cop slash assassin really
um
but now [ __ ] um Craig would have no
problem with that not uh yeah no um no I
wonder what that thing
uh Hardy Tom Hardy had no problem with
that role
he could be any any size you want him to
be depending on how you shoot him
he can get big when he needs to gets big
when he needs to just like big man in
Japan I gotta get big
you guys haven't seen that but if you
ever see big man in Japan please guys
you haven't seen it we did a review of
IT a while back we watched that movie
not knowing what it was about
and as it started to unfold that was one
of the [ __ ] just that was one of the
funniest ones
it's like it's low-key though it's not
zany no but see I like that I thought it
was serious I'd like that kind of until
I saw him get bad bit get big and the
[ __ ] got big baby you just gotta
see he's fighting like kg yeah yeah
that's like his job yeah so they're like
yeah they're bringing up all of these
really good gangster movies which like I
said layer cake I've told you about that
one Daniel Craig was in that actually
Long Good Friday that that one's amazing
um The Rock and roller I haven't seen
that one Get Carter that was like pretty
great uh Lock Stock and Two Smoking
Barrels also excellent yeah I was gonna
say like I think that much like a lot of
things in the 80s I think the whole
James Bond Roger Moore thing was because
it went more in a direction of as I said
like a lot of entertainment did in the
80s like in a more like Fantastical like
glamorous kind of Direction because
everything in the 80s had to be
glamorous you know what I mean like
everybody had to be rich and they had to
be like [ __ ] everybody had to be on
Yachts with diamonds on and big
everything was a Duran Duran video
that's what I was thinking I was like
everything had to be like a Duran Duran
video you know what I mean so it kind of
went in that direction which like I said
not so much from like from the books but
you talking about [ __ ] uh Bond yeah
so I think like just just like
everything else like kind of bond went
into more in an even more like fantasy
Direction in the 80s I watched one of
the supposedly worst Bond movies and I
believe it was Roger Moore
Moonraker and I liked it
I haven't seen boom breaker in a long
time and that was supposed to be one of
the worst ones I I liked it and it was a
response to uh Star Wars they said well
we gotta have a space movie you know it
was James Bond in space
[Laughter]
it was good it's it's not agree it was
not a gritty type movie but it was good
it's just kind of a fantasy movie you
know
let's go
dude's making a [ __ ] deadly virus to
wipe out the Earth and they're gonna
come down and [ __ ] reclaim the Garden
of Eden you know after everybody was
dead
man I can't count the number of times
that I've wanted to do the same exact
thing not really yeah it was a bunch of
[ __ ] uh Rich dudes and scientists and
genetically Superior people and all
their [ __ ] genetically beautiful
women [ __ ] and they had him on
[ __ ] all Races and everything
and they were going to repopulate the
Earth with [ __ ] good people getting
rid of all you garbage all you trashy
people that's really what it was about
we're gonna get rid of y'all you trashy
people
and come down and [ __ ] re-uh
recolonize the planet there's like
something out of [ __ ] um
out of [ __ ] uh [ __ ]
that Kubrick movie with the [ __ ]
Doctor Strange Love You know where
they're gonna they were going to repot
go down into the mine and come back and
repopulate it's like that they're gonna
be down there with all the hot women of
course we're gonna use a computer to
select the hottest of all women with all
the attributes and [ __ ] of course
it's gonna have to be a 10 to 1 ratio in
order to repopulate the planet fast
enough and they're like all these things
are like going like oh yeah this is a
great idea
typical yeah that's how it works
granther said if Roger Moore was ex-army
he was in the champagne Brigade that
yeah couldn't win a fight with his
bathroom no no
you could run through right now that's
awesome run through Roger more like
[ __ ] goose [ __ ] I mean I could
probably kick Roger yeah yeah yeah well
what I could probably kick his ass was
he dead yeah oh he's long dead well I
could really kick his ass now because
he's probably just like skeleton I think
he was [ __ ] pushing 60 in his last
movie with uh with uh James Bond I mean
they were making fun of it he was
getting a little they weren't old I
remember that he was getting a little
long in the tooth yeah well and I think
it wasn't even so much that he was
playing a secret agent because there's
nothing that scary but they would always
pair him with like [ __ ] 23 year old
women yeah it's like yeah that looks
like your [ __ ] granddaughter dude
yeah yeah
although what's funny is that he never
really they never really make out or
seem to have sex once they got real old
it was just kind of like the side kick
from what I can remember well I haven't
seen any of those in a long time she
kind of like because maybe like they did
it on the set and they're like no that's
right
it's like like I said it's like making
out with my granddaughter that's like
really nasty
when it came to the bond franchise
the missed opportunity was Dalton
because that first Dalton movie was good
it was almost like a Daniel Craig movie
it was it was gritty for the day
not by today's standards but by that
that day status it was and then they
softened it in the second one and he
didn't want to come back I guess
after that
I think there's some kind of problem
with contracts I don't remember what it
was but yeah I think we reviewed that
movie and I think we might have talked
about it but I don't remember like what
all the specifics were
they should have stayed with that
grittier
um
formula because Living Daylights was was
good that could have been kind of a
people weren't ready for that they were
ready for it like now they are now
everything is like a gritty reboot and
like everything is dark so everyone's
just kind of like okay whatever but it's
like back then I think people were like
not ready for it yet
and Dalton was believable you know I
think he might have been late 40s early
50s but he was
um in good enough shape to where it was
believable that these
late 20s or mid-20s girls would be
interested in him yeah it didn't seem
quite as weird like he seemed older but
he didn't seem like he wasn't like an
old grandpa right yeah right like Roger
Moore like toward the end started like
Grandpa yeah which you know
and like I said that's not so much I
mean some of it's to do with like
chronological age but some of it's to do
with like wave is carrying himself yeah
so I think that's kind of what it was
and well you could you could believe
that Dalton might kick your ass
yeah he might shoot you right I could
never believe that [ __ ] Roger Moore
would shoot you
yeah he would just he would just make a
witty quit yeah yeah yeah that was the
problem
and then just kind of like yeah go and
take a sip from but don't look like he
might shoot you and he pulled a gun on
you yeah yeah
they're talking about Hot Fuzz yeah
I feel like he was in a lot of stuff but
who Timothy Dalton oh yeah I liked him
in [ __ ] Flash Gordon
that's right I forgot he was in that
yeah
brilliant movie man [ __ ] especially
on Blu-ray man
the way it was meant to be seen on the
big screen and [ __ ] high definition
it was a fun movie
and uh true to the source material
if that's you know if that's your thing
but that kind of was you know for me
Zach says for me Timothy Dalton is the
most handsome Bond
Pierce Brosnan is almost too pretty to
be believable
yeah but he had some good
he had some good uh movies golden eye I
remember is being really good
I really like golden eye and golden eye
was a lot like Living Daylights
the budget was bigger though
but then I remember the Pierce Brosnan
when starting to get a little [ __ ]
Khan zany
like
um that last one
that he did was kind of Madonna did a
theme song it was it was the one where
he gets uh captured by the North Koreans
at first then he gets out
did I see that yeah yeah I have it I
have
I have I mean I feel like I've watched
all I've probably seen like all the Bond
films at some point in my 50 years of
life but they all kind of like blend
together to be honest with you I gotta
admit I've never seen any of the old
ones
well you've never seen any of the Sean
Connery ones no no they're all right
they're just look to dated for me I mean
I should go back and see some of them
but see that doesn't bother me though
because I you know you know me I really
like uh old movie I'll watch old movies
all day long so you know what I mean I
like all this like [ __ ] weird 70s
geology movies and [ __ ] like that so it
doesn't really bother me I'm willing to
like watch stuff in the context if it's
time but I remembered some of the Sean
Connery ones being good but like I said
I haven't seen them for a very very long
time if I was going to see one I'd see
one like maybe man with a golden gun
although Zach just said that I think
Zach just said that was his least
favorite at least everyone
I don't know the one with Donald
Pleasence where he's [ __ ] playing
um
um yeah
well I mean
I'll watch pretty much anything with
Donald Pleasence in it yeah although
Donald Pleasence was in some real turds
yeah yeah yeah like Puma man yeah
he probably thought he was going to be
in the next Superman too
[Laughter]
he's looking for a puma man
um if you haven't seen Puma man
that's bad it's an Italian knockoff of
Superman I guess it's supposed to be an
Italian dog of Superman but she wouldn't
really know that
um I thought a Mystery Science Theater I
would not advise watching it without
people riffing it but I mean the
actually the MST episode of it is one of
my favorite episodes because that movie
is just so [ __ ] ridiculous but yeah
Donald Pleasence is in it well what was
I was watching one of the older Mystery
Science Theater episodes the other day
um Warrior the lost world that was the
one that was like um like a
post-apocalyptic mad Maxi kind of [ __ ]
and um that was from the 80s and it had
persis combata in it from the Star Trek
movies so like you know what I mean yeah
and um Donald Pleasence was in that too
Donald Pleasence they're saying that
saying that
um
hold on Pierce Brosnan is easily the
best looking Bond but the problem is
that Bob was not described as good
looking that he was described as kind of
[ __ ] rugged and beat up look
he was he was magnetic women liked him
but he wasn't he wasn't a pretty boy
and then um Sasha red said the one with
Donald Pleasence was You Only Live Twice
You Live Twice yeah yeah that's right
I remember diamonds are forever I saw it
as a kid
I think that was a uh
um I remember liking it but I was a kid
and I think that was a uh that was that
wasn't Sean Connery
think that was Roger Moore that was in
that one yeah
I can't even remember him there's just
so many there's so many
yeah From Russia with Love that's
another one that
uh and Hugo said I also like on Her
Majesty's Secret Service from 1969.
that's the one that had that guy who's
only did one George Lazenby yeah yeah I
think it was an american guy wouldn't he
I think he just did one yeah it was
George lazy to be American I think he
was American
if I remember correctly
yeah yeah diamonds are forever with
Morris basically an adaptation of the
gemstone file underground manuscript I
should probably get those movies
yeah you should probably I mean nowadays
you can probably buy a whole [ __ ] box
set for yeah they have a whole series I
would get a used box set well yeah
holy [ __ ] I was looking the other day
because oh I think it was when I was
doing research for my um for my coal
shack uh video and I was curious to see
how much because Kolchak was like a big
influence on the X-Files and I was
curious to see how much they were
charging nowadays for the whole box set
of all the X-Files 300 something dollars
yeah but it's it's a massive massive
thing so X-Files huh yeah
you spend all year watching that [ __ ]
that's what I mean it's like God you
know what's weird I never got I never
started watching the Xbox like I'd
always like catch it every now and then
I'm like oh this seems like pretty good
like something that I would watch but I
just never sat down and watched it some
of the episodes were probably I should
because it sounds like something I would
like but it's just yeah it was kind of
like the Twilight Zone some of the
episodes were awesome I'm never gonna
live long enough to watch all the [ __ ] I
want to watch one of the episodes was is
uh
they had these uh crazy inbred
Confederates
they were the descendants of the
Confederates they had the mama her arms
and legs I think were missing they had
her on a dam
rolling board underneath the bed and
yeah
giving birth to all her children and
they were it was [ __ ] wild man it was
wild
all her sons were getting her pregnant
and then she was
making more children so that's how it is
in their family yeah
yeah it was [ __ ] bizarre Ben says
George Lazenby was Australian he was
Australian I knew he wasn't British I
thought he was American
Australia that's even worse
well I don't know at least like the
worst at least the accent is still okay
at least it's not like an American that
[ __ ] should have had a damn
California accent what's up man it's not
like keanuary yeah yeah yeah
man this is what Q gave
Swatch shoots out a laser
it comes out look it burns stuff up it's
gnarly
oh my God now I want to see [ __ ]
bogus man
I had to jump out of an airplane to my
parachute and everything had opened up I
even [ __ ] came down I was fluttering
down like like I was on a parachute man
I couldn't believe it dude didn't even
have a [ __ ] surfboard
it was wild man it was gnarly
now I want to see like a Bill and Ted
James Bond matchup yeah
James Bond's Excellent Adventure
James Bond Man James Bond's not James
Bond until he's from [ __ ] California
man
I'm from Diamond Bar
God damn it yeah
yeah I'm here man I'm a secret agent
don't tell anybody
watching you
well she got some Bodacious boobs man
that can't be natural no [ __ ] way
dude no that's not natural look how they
move man no that's not natural count
these [ __ ] boobs that's a silicone
sister right there dude I [ __ ] know
who installed those things we went to
school together
making billions making Bookoo bucks off
implants
I like the idea of um breast implants
being installed yeah installed man like
stereo components yeah yeah exactly
so I can stall and that's very that's
very funny yeah yeah yeah
thanks Gina just plug their Plug and
Play yes
makes it sound like [ __ ] high-tech
you know what I mean yeah [ __ ]
uh Zach says in the 70s the guy who
played Janet Lee's boyfriend in Psycho
was almost Bond and James Brolin was
almost bond in the 1980s James Brolin
from Amityville Horror you know what I
mean
that would have been something yeah
hopefully she would shave all that hair
that he had an Amityville Horror because
uh wow that was a lot of hair a lot of
hair that was [ __ ] popular at the
time that was cool well I know yeah I've
seen pictures of my dad from that area
yeah so I know what that looks like yeah
my dad had a full beard and everything
yeah mine did too yeah mine did too
um let's see
yeah Daniel the third time about Earth
Girls Are Easy holy [ __ ] I haven't seen
that movie in a long time
um In Like Flint I remember that an army
and Flint yeah with James Coburn like
spy spoofs kinda
Jillian Anderson American or English
I thought she was Canadian to be honest
with you I don't really know
I don't really know
Jillian Anderson like where she was from
Anderson sounds familiar like from the
X-Files oh her yeah it's like for some
reason I thought she was Canadian but I
don't know I thought I'm probably wrong
about that
laughs
slasher friend said in the opening of
Friday the 13th Part 6 Jason lives
there's a spoof of the famous James Bond
gun barrel scene yeah that's right they
did like a James Bond spoof in the
beginning of the Friday the 13th because
why not
why not they've done everything else in
that [ __ ] in that [ __ ] [ __ ]
John Smith said MI6 have a recruitment
page on their website they've removed
the claws that at least one of your
parents must be born in the UK
isn't that interesting that they had
that to start with
Ben said she's English isn't she is she
where's she from I don't know I
genuinely don't know
that's not interesting that they had
that they want to make sure that people
were loyal to their country well I know
that but I'm just saying it's like I
don't know that's I guess that never
occurred to me Zach said um intelligence
ages also as is well known if you grab a
woman's [ __ ] and one of her nipples she
takes a screenshot
and it makes that noise like a Mac mix
like when you take a screenshot like an
old school camera
uh we'll take a screenshot of like
whatever we're [ __ ] looking at I like
that idea I like that idea
uh Tom and Jenny favorite Christmas
movies
oh Christmas Chronicles [ __ ] Crustle
yeah he likes both I mean yeah he play
he plays a good like he's not a cranky
thing he's a curmudgeon lisanta like but
he's still lovable die hard yeah I like
black Christmas Lethal Weapon
does that count yeah there's actually
like some really good Christmas horror
movies if you haven't seen a Christmas
Horror Story which is an anthology movie
and it has the chat in the in the uh and
he gets drunker and drunker like as the
movie goes on much like this show
so yeah it's like super and Krampus is
in it Santa fights Krampus
there's like big like Santa versus
Krampus fisticuffs at the end they're
zombie elves it's it's pretty fantastic
yeah I like that movie a lot
uh yeah she is English okay
who knew I thought I don't know why I
thought she was Canadian but
uh Cheryl says Friday the 13th part six
is my favorite I think I don't remember
six
I haven't well we have
all of them right no no we don't have
all of them we just have a one and two
and maybe three
two is my favorite
yeah two is the best one through yeah
two's the best one I think two is one
yeah well because I like um Amy Steele
like she's because the thing about the
Friday the 13th franchise is that you
barely remember like any of the people
that get [ __ ] murdered in it right
like you only remember Jason but Amy
Steele was such a
memorable character that she actually
kind of like stuck out like amid all of
the other
machete fodder one and two scared the
[ __ ] out of me when I was a kid
going to Mississippi for the summer
I see my dad
but I'd spend the [ __ ] weekends at my
[ __ ] cousin my cousin's house cousin
David
and uh
we would stay up late watching [ __ ]
Cinemax and [ __ ]
and they would play Friday the 13th
seemed like every year they'd have a new
friend they'd play them all like one two
and three or one two three and four you
know as the years went on
and those seem to scare the [ __ ] out of
me and then you go go back and look at
them man there's not a lot of blood in
them there's not a lot of Gore in them
really but at these stairs but they
would just scared you back then
and uh
that was in Laurel Mississippi where he
lived
and it was real rural during in those
days
and at night you had to close the dab
Shades because you're afraid because
when you looked out the window and it
was just black this out there
so you were afraid that Jason was
looking in that window even though the
back side of his house was two floors
off the ground because the house [ __ ]
went out like that it was on stilt
slightly you know what I'm talking about
I mean Jason you couldn't stand up that
hot time and look in the window but we
had to shut the [ __ ] Windows man and
there was Woods out behind there we were
afraid [ __ ] Jason was out there in
those woods we nearly burned them Woods
down a couple years later I told that
story on the show with gasoline and
shotguns and swinging through the
[ __ ] wall of fire on the [ __ ]
don't let redneck children have gasoline
and shotguns just a pro tip yeah or
fireworks or anything all the things
that the south is filled with
redneck Boy southern regular boys have
that [ __ ] you know and uh not it's all
the southerners the black [ __ ] of
Southern boys just as bad [ __ ]
because you don't have any supervision
you're in the wild so you can go feral
you know the adults aren't going to be
around you're gonna steal your dad's
gasoline out of the out of the [ __ ]
garage you're gonna grab the [ __ ]
duck shotgun the Mini-14 and all that
and get his [ __ ] trap shells and go
out and [ __ ] shoot some [ __ ] up he's
not even gonna miss it
because he's buying some would you guys
shooting the shotgun yeah we've been
shooting the shot he's not gonna care
you know man we would do some wild [ __ ]
out there but we nearly burned those
[ __ ] Woods down
I don't know how we survived
I don't know either
the gas can caught on fire and it was
plastic
that was [ __ ] oh man I don't want to
get back into that into that [ __ ]
man
yeah yeah I can't believe we supposed to
survived that [ __ ] I was trying to put
the [ __ ] fire out donkey dick of the
gasoline was [ __ ] melting on fire
like a fuse and I was trying to put it
out and I don't know how that [ __ ] so
would you like jump on it or roll on it
we ran from it once you got your product
it's gonna blow we just ran them
the fire went up and it [ __ ] went
into the trees but it burned out it was
too wet
you know I mean yeah it's the south in
the summer it's raining every day you
know yeah it's some humidity yeah the
air is the air is wet
that's
gross
yeah
Cheryl said best Christmas horror movies
black Christmas better watch out oh yeah
better watch out is really good too uh
P2 Christmas evil and rare exports yeah
rare exports is really good too they're
talking about violent night which is a
new one and yeah I've that's in the
theaters right now and I actually do
want to see that because that's got
David Harper in it from stranger things
and he's awesome and I've heard that
it's like really really good like a yeah
it's like a Christmas horror movie yeah
and I mean there's a lot of Christmas
horror movies but I feel like most of
them are not good yeah like I feel like
most of the ones that have been
mentioned are the good ones yeah I liked
Krampus that was like a good one too
like that was a fun movie
um
John Smith said as kids we would uh
throw aerosol cans on bonfires nearly
blur I'm sorry you might be Southern too
hey grafters I think he's British
British hey granters when um
because grafters knew me a couple years
after that
when I ended up in Michigan in high
school with him oh and Gremlins yeah
yeah grab this I don't know I I kind of
kept it under wraps you know where I had
been
um did people know that I was Southern I
don't know if I even had an accent
because I could change my accent I
sounded like whoever was around me after
a while
that's Jenny when I'm talking to my dad
the transformation that
but I don't even know if people knew I
was from the south
in in Michigan
you know Steve did no my friends did but
I don't think anybody else really do
yeah I don't really I don't know like um
I never thought of myself as having a
particularly southern accent but maybe I
do like if other like do you think I do
yeah if you moved up the Northeast you
went to uh Boston or uh New York you'd
have an accent it wouldn't necessarily
be a Southern accent
because a lot of a lot of Florida
doesn't really have it depending on
your parents have it
yeah or at least your mom I haven't
heard your dads they have it my dad's is
more than that because my dad is from
Tennessee yeah my mom is actually from
Baltimore okay well your mom has a
southern I mean that's where she was
born she was born in Baltimore but I
think she moved down here like when she
was a teenager or maybe something like
that
you could easily be from the Gulf Coast
of Mississippi Gulf Coast of Mississippi
is the same as as Florida Panhandle
now people are moving into that area
but they end up just becoming Southern
in a generation or actually just an over
a matter of time you know I go to that
damn biker bar which is [ __ ] Southern
as [ __ ]
and they got guys from Minnesota in
there I ran into a dude from Minnesota
his [ __ ] accent was atrocious
okay and then they got some other
Yankees up in there some of them have
been here for so long that they now have
Southern Accents
I guess you just kind of start blending
in well it depends on the person but
it's like you just kind of tend to if
you're around other people all the time
that talk different like you tend to
like pick up right you know what I mean
well I mean the same thing happened to
me like when I was going back and forth
to the UK all the time I didn't like
develop a British accent like I'm not
Madonna but you know what I mean it was
just kind of like I did kind of start to
pick up
the slang and the Cadence and things
like that because you're just around
people you're around at all times you're
just around it all the time so yeah
that's I didn't mean for it to happen
but when I came back my parents were
like wow you kind of sound like a
British person well the weird thing is
that when I was over there yeah
um all the people in Wales where I was
thought I sounded Irish yeah well when I
was in Boston people thought that I was
Irish
which I was like um no because they're
they have Irish in Boston yeah but they
thought that I was Irish but no it was
it it's just it's kind of a neutral-ish
Southern accent
um it's just that we don't really
perceive it as as Southern but
depends on if we're on our best behavior
or not also too but
because I noticed like if I'm around a
bunch of Southerners they start getting
drunk I sound more and more Southern
because I start just going into that
mode you know
but um no you go up North and no we
don't sound like them
like that dude from [ __ ] Minnesota he
was like from another country well the
Minnesota accent is very distinctive
yeah Midwestern whoa this dude here man
and he's trying to fit in and out talk
about motorcycles and you know I'm being
courteous to him but I was going like
this dude's Fish Out of Water he just
moved here
you know and he's biker but I just sound
like he's from it's out of Scandinavian
well yeah that's what that's what that
accent sounds like is that like
something from Sweden yeah
I've heard a lot of people from
Minnesota yeah that's what they sound
like yeah well see well the funny thing
about it is that I guess I'm kind of
more familiar with it because you know
I'm a big fan of Mystery Science Theater
and a lot of them are from Minnesota and
so they kind of make fun of that yeah
accent all the time so they'll do like a
little Riff on like that people the way
that people talk up there yeah so you
know what I mean
laughs
um
Richard Brown said is that why you like
British films so much Jenny
um I actually liked them before I went
over there I don't know why I was just
always kind of like I don't know it was
just always kind of like an anglophile I
guess like from a pretty young age I
liked well I think it was because I
liked a lot of um when I was a kid I
liked a lot of um like new wave and I
like so I liked a lot of British music
so I think that just kind of like
extended to the culture at large so I
got into like a lot of British movies
and stuff and then like when I went over
there and got like more familiar with
the culture I guess I got like more into
it
um
El Patronus said no disrespect but Tom
kind of looks like wrestler Kevin
Sullivan I don't know who that is I
don't know that much about wrestling
I don't know that much about wrestling
yeah Oscar says he finds it peculiar
that I say Of All Times yeah times with
a s
you have set different times of all
times not all time
at all times it's even better
because times are in little discreet
packages
there's that time and another time and
this time and that time back with the
times
Victor said hey I made it yeah you did
I mean we're not that drunk yet really
yeah we're not going out afterwards no
we're gonna get drunk so we can just
kind of sit here and get drunk so that
sounds like that and I got all kinds of
good food downstairs he's already he's
already thinking about that man I made
some pulled pork that was really good
yeah yeah we had like a little bit yeah
my own [ __ ] macaroni and cheese
and rice and macaroni and cheese is good
yeah that Mac and Cheese came out good
yeah
I gotta get some more macaroni elbows
I got that five pound box of macaroni
elbows from [ __ ] Walmart
for like a couple bucks it was well
spent more though let me get some more
of those it's like the size of a cereal
box
it's good I could eat all that just yeah
yeah that's like three servings
get those big [ __ ] Tupperware
containers of macaroni and cheese
speaking of which you know
um
speaking of like all you can eat and
like lots of food and stuff I was
telling you about the restaurant that we
went to
at Disney Springs it's actually not as
Disney Springs it's a um
the Disney Polynesian Resort yeah that's
where we went at eight like with my for
my sister's birthday this place is
called Ohana and apparently there's like
a really big like waiting list right
like because it was really hard for her
to get um you know reservations what
they do they only have like a I guess
what they call like a prefix menu it's
all kind of Polynesian like Flavor food
but they it's all you can eat I think
it's like 50 it's a flat 59 fee
you come in you sit around the table and
they just bring you
all the food you want like they bring
you salad and bread first when you
finish that they ask you if you want any
more if you don't they live they they
bring you like more stuff and they bring
you like like I said it's like four or
five or six different things there's
like these kind of like um chicken wings
and legs it's like of these really
really good noodles they have like all
kind of they have broccoli they had some
kind of like chimichurri like kind of
chicken they had like some big chunks of
steak they had like shrimp and all and
they just keep bringing it and keep
bringing it and keep bringing it like as
much as your table can eat and they will
just do that all night man we need to go
to the Brazilian High School
Camp guy said yeah Ohana's in the
Tahitian Polynesian yeah that's where we
went it's one of the top level places
inside the Disney we're gonna go to
[ __ ] Texas to Brazil yeah I still
wanted to go there alone you'll like it
I think it's about 80 bucks a plate I
think now it's expensive but it's all
you can eat
Brazilian barbecue I used to have it
when I was in Brazil it's [ __ ] great
man see that sounds yummy
they have everything man bisteka
that have [ __ ] hump of the Brahma
Bull they probably have all that uh
[ __ ] Lumber de Porco which is [ __ ]
pork 10 pork tenderloin uh different
cuts of [ __ ] beef and they bring it
along on a [ __ ] sword the Gaucho
[ __ ] cuts it off of a big old [ __ ]
sword
sword full of [ __ ] roasted chicken
hearts salted really good man barbecue
chicken hearts are [ __ ] sitting there
eating them
and then uh dessert carts and side carts
they [ __ ] bring those by
and um
drink [ __ ] kashasa or caipania
which is kind of like
I like kaipur Oscar which is just vodka
and crushed lime and sugar on Ice
[ __ ] that's that's like their their
national drink is pinga which is kind of
like Everclear
with crushed lime and sugar
with over ice really good
um
just it's a great barbecue Brazilians
know how to barbecue it's just this
different they don't use a tomato based
barbecue sauce it's just salted and
seasoned really good
and they'll use things like vinaigrette
and some called far Offa which is like
cracked
wheat
and it's kind of like it looks like
sawdust kind of but it's [ __ ]
beautiful you roll the meat in like this
cracked wheat and eat it
hmm
yeah Camp guy said uh the Character
Breakfast is a great deal at Ohana yeah
they were talking about that
um and it did actually sound really good
but some of the restaurants in the
Disney Resorts
um you can't get in the [ __ ] like you
have to make reservations like months
and months ahead my sister told me that
because she came down like just for a
few days
and she wanted to do like the after
hours because you know like at like
Disney during this time period because
me and her went to the Halloween one but
around Christmas they do like Disney's
Hollow like uh Christmas whatever and
she said all the dates had sold out
though like so she couldn't do them like
all of them were gone and most of the
restaurants all the reservations were
used up like way into the new year yeah
you know what I mean but she said that
breakfast was supposed to be there good
there too but she wanted to eat at this
place because she'd never eaten there
before and it was really really good it
was me and my sister and my two brothers
and my sister-in-law yeah and we were
just kind of like man we were so [ __ ]
stuffed and oh and they bring you
dessert too which is like a pineapple
bread pudding with like ice like
homemade ice cream on it and that was
like really good grandpar said uh the
thing about all those all you can eat
Brazilian places is the law of
diminishing returns yeah it's in real
quick well that's kind of like yeah like
when we were at this one there were five
of us
and I don't think like they brought
seconds on a couple of things but not
much because
man even with five of us they were
bringing so much food that we were just
kind of like holy [ __ ] like we can't and
by the time the dessert came I had like
a tiny little piece of it and I'm just
like yeah I'm just I can't eat anymore I
said I'm gonna throw up Graham said that
in high school they didn't know I was
Southern that's good I was Incognito I
didn't want to [ __ ] attract that much
attention and then um
he says tomorrow uh him and Steve buddy
of mine they're gonna build Steve's
first AR together they're going to
assemble it yeah if you got to have the
you want to have a vice and you want to
have that assembly jig to help you
[ __ ] tighten down that barrel nut you
got to tighten that [ __ ] to spec I
forgot the spec on it but you'll know
but it's an easy build it's an easy
build building lowers to
it's more like it's just assembly
more than anything else building is AK
and I've [ __ ] done over the time when
I was younger I haven't done it a long
time I did four AKs that's all rivet
work and pulling a [ __ ] install in a
barrel or pulling a barrel out of an AK
trillion is a [ __ ] [ __ ] you're gonna
need buckets of ice water and a [ __ ]
torch and a [ __ ] Vise and a rubber
mallet to get that [ __ ] because it's
slip fit
and it just pressed in there with a
[ __ ] press and to get it in and out a
civilian trying to get it in and out
without that press you're gonna have to
heat that truck you end up red hot and
knock that Barrel out of there and then
[ __ ] put a new Barrel in and dump the
thing in ice water and it [ __ ]
and then you're gonna have to [ __ ] do
all the rivet work to get the [ __ ]
front and rear trunnion back in the
receiver is a [ __ ] but AKs are
satisfying to [ __ ] [ __ ] build man
especially back in the day for 250 bucks
you could get an 8K into militarized AK
kit and reassemble it on a no Dax Bud
receiver
I got it I got an alpha AK
uh built a hand-built alpha AK in the
other room with a [ __ ] moderator and
everything
um it started off as an AMD 65 but uh
now I'm into all that [ __ ] too
can't show it on a stream they'll
[ __ ] cut the stream you touch a
[ __ ] gun on a live stream to cut it
uh AI does it I think
AI recognizes it somehow
at least so I heard
yeah I was going to tell a camp guy too
like when I was
um there before we went to Ohana we
actually went we took the monorail and
we went into the um Grand Floridian and
in the lobby of the Grand Floridian they
had a store that was selling gingerbread
and candy and stuff like that and it was
an actual life-size gingerbread house
that was made out of actual gingerbread
and you could like actually buy like
gingerbread and stuff in there American
Military 100 said have you guys seen 10
to midnight uh the Charles Bronson movie
I saw it a while back I actually put it
in the poll a couple of times like to do
but it never won but uh he said Charles
Bronson was definitely not committed was
probably just a Canon contract for a
flick for him I remember liking it but
it's been a while since I've seen it you
know what I'm saying
you know what I mean yeah okay several
guys in there talking about my build
and uh new listeners asking for pointers
trying to get built up
thank you
um you can go back
and look at earlier episodes and see
that I've only really been built like
this recently I've been working for how
long
three years
but I've been enhanced for about two
when you I'm asking you Jenny how long
how would I know I don't know you don't
you don't know how long ago it was I
started well okay I think I don't keep I
got my own [ __ ]
I can't keep track of your [ __ ] I don't
know my sense of time isn't all that
good
all right here's my here's the pointer I
don't know how old you are
if you're over 35 you'll never be built
like me it won't happen
not unless you've um
dealt with your testosterone issue
you've got to [ __ ] be on
um enhancement you've got to go on HRT
all right after 35 you just don't make
enough
if you're young you could get built
about like me naturally if you're a
[ __ ] genetically gifted but after 35
you're gonna have to go on testosterone
replacement therapy
that will allow your body to respond
to the training that you're doing
you'll get like me
um now it might take time and if time is
a factor you have to speed it up because
you're older
so then you're gonna have to do
therapeutic cycles of other things I'd
recommend like Winstrol
uh
I'm not a doctor I can't give medical
advice I'm just telling you how other
people do it I didn't do it this way
but when straw will work
Diana ball
um
tranbolone
uh masteron there's you have to go to
study what other dudes did
cheat your ass off and lift a bunch of
weight and it'll it'll come it'll come
there's a science to it you can get
involved in the [ __ ]
Fitness and bodybuilding and I'm not a
pro bodybuilder I'm not looking to be
ifbb or anything like that I'm just gym
rat style and uh fighting off age
if you're over 40 go on [ __ ] HRT it's
the best thing you'll ever do you don't
have to do the other [ __ ]
half the battle is at HRT you'll feel so
much better you'll sleep better you'll
just be a lot more healthy you're made
if you're a man you're made to have that
testosterone in you
put it put it back in there and you'll
feel a lot better everything will work a
lot better and you'll live longer okay
I've seen the data it's it's beneficial
okay the other stuff could be a
trade-off depending on
if you're abusing it or not I don't
abuse anything I just use things and
it's very it's therapeutic levels
minimum doses minimum effective
so that's that's my advice okay
El padrino said damn I'm 45 I'm [ __ ]
but I'll check into it the HRT go on HRT
hey I'm almost 55.
that's true I'm almost 55. I went on
HRT in my late 40s
so you're not it's not too late
I went on around
50 I think 49 or 50. because when I went
on each yeah because I don't think
you've been on it that long no
that's only been a couple of I've been
on HRT for three years I go on and off
anabolics for about two years now right
maybe only a year like I said I'm not
really maybe only a year yeah I remember
you going to the clinic because I went
with you a couple of times yeah when we
lived at the old house but you know we
we only moved from the old house like a
year and a half ago if you have no idea
what you're doing if you don't know how
to run [ __ ] cryptocurrency and vpns
and you're not worried about getting in
your own [ __ ] go to a HRT clinic near
you Google that go see those dudes have
about a thousand dollars at hand expect
to pay about 200 bucks a month and for
about six months to a year go under
their supervision and they'll teach you
how to use testosterone once that's out
of the way then you can go on to other
stuff but they'll they'll show you how
to do it
under a doctor's supervision but you
want to do it under doctor's supervision
first until you learn the ropes
yeah until you know what you're doing
right L Petrina said uh HRT is what yeah
it's uh hormone replacement therapy yeah
yeah that's all
Ben says is this the same as the growth
hormones that are illegal in Australia
no Stallone got fined for having
somebody's luggage a few years ago no
one can understand why no he was on
eight he was on uh GH growth hormone
for a wild growth hormone
was considered to be a safe alternative
to or a safer alternative to anabolic
steroids it's not really
it's pretty safe but it it has a weird
side effect if you use too much it can
cause your lips and your nose to grow
which kind of had happened to him but he
fixed it
GH is really only good for pro
bodybuilders that are damn near maxed
out on anabolics and they can throw in
some GH and get a little bit bigger but
if you're not planning on stepping on
stage and being a pro bodybuilder you
will never really have to [ __ ] with GH
although some people have said if you
get older you're in your 50s or 60s and
you're on HRT and anabolics a little bit
of GH can help you but we're talking
about a little bit
you know um we're talking about
therapeutic doses not abusive abusive
doses so
you got to look at
the studies and what other people have
done so GH might be all right
but it's got to be
very reasonable Doses and it has to be
in a packet or what we call a stack a
stack of a bunch of other therapies that
you're doing this is for old guys not
really for young guys older guys
you look at all these Superstar dudes
are looking [ __ ] fantastic Jason
Statham The Rock and all they're doing
what I'm doing it's not natural
you can't look like this being natural
this is the male version of breast
implants really well like I said go back
to the old days and like look at 50 60
year old men looking back from the yeah
they all look like old dudes okay old
man can you stop this [ __ ] you will
revert back to an old man or in a few
years
so it's a therapy that you have to keep
up with your body needs to have these
things in it to keep you in that shape
because you can't make it on your own
you're too old
yeah that's what we were talking about
that the other day about how like much
older people looked back right back in
the old days
probably I mean due to a lot of reasons
I think but I'm sure that was one yeah
he says oh 45 I'm too [ __ ] old 45 I
was natural dude dude I'm 50. I'm almost
55. yeah you're not too old I'm 15.
Now's the Time yeah
had I know what I know now I'd have gone
on at 40. so 45 you'd be good it's early
compared to my you get go on go on HRT
go see your local doctor your local
Clinic get on HRT
you need about seven hundred dollars for
that first month and then about 200 per
month after that but you'll feel so much
better you're like oh man this is great
then once you learn the ropes
you'll realize you'll be able to get
that same thing for about 60 bucks on
the black market
yeah because there's a black market for
it and it's good [ __ ]
all that stuff's easy to make
just have to have a good online source
that says uh Jenny have you ever played
with AI art generation I'm using one for
story ideas I have and it's really fun
no I haven't but it is kind of something
I'm interested in so if you have
anything like any recommendations along
that
line then let me know
because you know I might get back like I
said I'm trying to in the New Year I'm
kind of hoping to
like I said I might do
fewer videos every week just so I can
get more so I can work more on like my
um my games and my fiction and stuff
like that because I'd really like to get
back to doing some of that kind of stuff
El Paterno said 45 272 pounds six feet
Barrel ass trying to get back into shape
272 you're overweight okay six feet tall
six feet that's still low go on HRT and
you'll start losing a lot of weight
because that happens when your
testosterone levels are low and then the
fatter you get the lower your
testosterone levels get so it's a
vicious cycle go on HRT you'll lose a
bunch of weight quick
yeah especially it starts working it's
much easier for dudes to lose weight
yeah because your [ __ ] starts working
better uh testosterone is the hormone
that's given the signals to all these
cells to actually do their jobs
and when it when it gets real low they
just sit back and say oh [ __ ] it
get fat
and eventually it kills you diabetes and
[ __ ] high blood pressure and all that
go on HRT and it'll [ __ ] [ __ ] will
start working again and you'll lose some
weight if you start working out it'll
even accelerate you'll build muscle mass
and lose fat
beef up
you'll feel a lot better too you'll be
able to sleep a lot better rest up
sit around like a lion eating meat he's
getting [ __ ] pretty
eating meat and getting pretty that's
what that's what Tom's biography
[Laughter]
[Music]
speaking of which when are we gonna make
some of those eight other turkeys we
have in the [ __ ] freezer
[Laughter]
yeah I just thought we we still have
eight turkeys in the in the freezer
they were really cheap at Publix you
know they were 42 cents a pound and I
love turkey
uh Zach says mid-journey is the most
popular one but it's a subscription
service well you know all the best stuff
is
I mean I can't afford it right now but
ten dollars a month but it only lets you
make about 200 images still though I
mean that's probably more than I would
use
I can't believe how expensive some [ __ ]
is though man because it's like I only
have
honestly I have to have at least one you
know stock art service because I do so
much graphic design work and I have
dreams time and if that's like 30
[ __ ] dollars a month and I also have
story blocks for you know video clips
and stuff and that's three that was 300
but for like a whole year
you know what I mean but I don't know if
I'm gonna renew it though because I kind
of feel like that's a little pricey
and their search engine is not fantastic
like I find it really really difficult
to find things like either I get nothing
or I get like a bajillion videos and it
takes me like ages to like find what I
want you know what I mean I don't know
and I I get that I'm like looking for
weird things sometimes but come on
but come on I mean ten dollars a month
is like pretty reasonable though I feel
like
one of these days if when I actually
have some money I should probably get
get the [ __ ]
all the new Adobe stuff because I'm
still working on like old like Adobe
like Photoshop and illustrator and
InDesign like six
you know
I had a trial of like the new like the
the online Photoshop like whatever
they're calling it but
man I just I can't afford it it's like
everything's too [ __ ] expensive you
know
everything's too expensive everybody
wants like five dollars a year and ten
dollars there and it's just like [ __ ]
man
I just I can't afford it
can't afford it uh let me see uh
Albertina said thanks guys I'll look
into this and keep watching your earlier
videos well thank you we're glad that
you found us yeah we have many many many
many videos we've been doing this since
2016. I think we started in the summer
of 2016. and when we started we only did
I feel like we only did one show a week
like we did a you know we would usually
just do a paranormal show or something
like that but then like slowly we
started adding more [ __ ] so like we
added a movie review and then we added
more like more movie reviews and then
just like now we were just like putting
up millions of things like every week
you know what I mean
um yeah Danny Rowling said Peace Out
gonna go check out the underwater review
okay well I hope you enjoy it I think
that we I think that was one of the ones
that we because remember for a for a
time like after we first got the um the
AMC Stubs uh you know subscription we
would do like field reviews like we
would go see a movie and then we would
like review it like as soon as we came
out and I think that's what we did on
that one
I'm still paying for that [ __ ] too and
we never even go to the [ __ ] movie
theater no we haven't gone in a while
that's like 20 a month that we're just
like pissing away well we need to cut it
off or we can start going back but
evidently the movie's been sucking
lately well I don't know there's been
tons of stuff I wanted to see we just
never go because it's far now it's far
and we you should never seem to have
time well yeah that's true well because
and that's another thing it's like
that's far so it's like you kind of need
like all day there needs to be one up
here if there's one up here we'd go
yeah you know what I mean I can't
believe there's not a movie theater
closer under the present economy they'll
never build an AMC up there AMC's in bad
danger for going out of the bank you
know what's weird though like when I was
uh when I was at Disney Springs they
have a massive [ __ ] AMC in there yeah
and it's [ __ ] packed
and it's still there like it was there
like a long time ago when [ __ ] virgin
Megastore was still there last I heard
they're basically bankrupt I mean yeah
but I'm just saying that it's like they
do have like you know they they do still
have like a bunch of theaters open
and they're losing money
El padrino said uh we're talking about
our old videos
um I got hooked I found a video and been
a fan since Tuesday night and caught the
live Wednesday so it's a very new yeah
you're a new listener yeah so it's like
I was I was like man you got we've done
so many [ __ ] I don't even know how
many [ __ ] videos thank you man put
out the put out the word for us go out
and uh get some friends to join up we're
always uh trying to expand
yeah I mean we've done like subscribers
and 300 something shows plus like I
don't even know how many movie reviews
I've done book reviews I've done movie
reviews like by myself right Jen just
like [ __ ] tons of stuff we're also um
looking for patrons because we've lost a
lot of patrons over the past year or so
two years because of the [ __ ] covet
and it's just were being decimated we
went from making 600 bucks a month in
patronage to [ __ ] only 300.
which it was okay but we could we could
get by on that but
buying the new house and uh a bunch of
other stuff and other business sources
of revenue slowing down that 300 made a
big difference it did yeah it made a big
difference
and um especially for the holidays
yeah like in the past couple months man
[ __ ] you guys yeah I understand it
you know people have [ __ ] holiday
bills coming up you know I mean so but
they stopped buying from us see yeah
well like I said and it's not just us
everybody all entertainment starts
taking a [ __ ] hit yeah because you
have to like it's the same thing with me
I'm just kind of like sitting there
going it's like oh yeah I Gotta Buy
people for presents so I gotta like cut
off this that thing that's just what
happens
uh Michael says Tom I'm 42. I need
testosterone therapy advice what did you
do specifically go to an HRT Clinic all
right I'm not a doctor go to an HRT
Clinic go put HR HRT clinic near me in
the Google [ __ ] search and hit it and
you're going to see clinics pop up in
your area go down there and see you go
down there and see him
expect to pay around 600 bucks for that
first month
because there's consultations blood work
and then your first month of [ __ ]
drugs
uh then after that it's about 200 bucks
a month
they should be giving you
200 milligrams of [ __ ] testosterone a
week
and 1000 IU of HCG a week
your doctor explained what that does
HCG is a [ __ ] pituitary gland
stimulant it's [ __ ] wonderful [ __ ]
okay
if it's a cheaper clinic they'll give
you Clomid that's okay I prefer HCG
though
have them teach you the ropes on how to
use that how to inject into yourself
that first [ __ ] you won't feel
anything for about three weeks and then
like [ __ ] week four it hits you like
a [ __ ] ton of brick you go through
puberty part two you think you're
[ __ ] 16. you're trying to jump
[ __ ] your girlfriend's bones
constantly you're just [ __ ] nuts
you're like man I haven't felt this wave
in a long time you know you think you're
14 and [ __ ]
then it starts then it stabilizes after
a few weeks you feel good but you don't
feel so drunk on it you know it's just
that your body's been starving for
for it for so long
then you start sleeping more and getting
better rested and you start healing up
you'll be real [ __ ] sore
because all the maintenance is
backlogged in you if you're in your 40s
you're not fully healed up
you're just not making enough androgens
a couple months later you're like man
I'm ready to go into the gym you're
going to the gym you'll get big big or
quick everything starts responding you
diet you actually lose weight you run
you lose weight you work out you gain
muscle lose weight it's everything is
[ __ ] working you can I don't want to
say you can eat like [ __ ] but you can
eat a lot like when you were a teenager
and your body processes it because the
signals are all being sent
now be aware
HRT is a gateway
into anabolic steroids because
if you're on HRT and you're an old man
you don't have to worry about
testosterone suppression anymore young
guys are always worried about getting
testosterone suppression and [ __ ]
post Psychotherapy and coming upstairs
because you're never going to come off
this test you're going to be on this for
the rest of your life
so that means you're always going to
have testosterone in your system so you
can jump on and off steroids at will
without any [ __ ] ill effects you
won't gain fat or get fat or in that
[ __ ]
so steroids are out there so you just
take them you just get bigger
get bigger feel better
you know the steroids are over your head
don't matter you're just still taking
the [ __ ] tests so
just be aware
once you start on HRT you'll get better
you'll feel better you'll live longer
but you'll also say you know what I'm
going to take these steroids for a
little bit and you'll do six weeks of
that and then jump off of it and go wow
that was great
month later you'll go you know what give
me some more of those
but you're not dealing with the downside
because you're now long you're no longer
a mortal man
you know [ __ ] steroids will [ __ ] with
a mortal man it'll shut his testosterone
production down you don't have to worry
about testosterone production because
you're an old man you don't have
testosterone production
those days are over
yours is coming out of a [ __ ] bottle
okay so that means you're now free to
take that [ __ ]
that's why these old dudes are looking
so [ __ ] jacked in these movies
okay that's all I'm going to say about
it for right now Jenny's getting mad she
don't want me talking about well I'm
just I'm getting behind with the
question yeah but yours you also got
behind with his commercials
well you want a commercial you keep
talking okay
um are you guys on Facebook yes yeah uh
we have our own personal Pages we have a
13 o'clock page uh I have Pages for my
other
yeah I have Pages for my other uh
channels which are the scare salon and
crime and Memorial uh yeah we have
Instagram I got an Instagram he's got an
Instagram that where he just shows
pictures of his chest all the time if
you're into that and I'm in the damn
microphone I'm in a biker bar I'm a
[ __ ] Amy throwing her titties in the
camera and [ __ ] you'll like it it's fun
Amy wants to be on the show
she met you she was like oh I liked her
she was cool
yeah I finally did go down there
uh where's your store we have like um
okay so I have a Zazzle store which has
some shirts on it we have these shirts
here like that one right there like we
screen print those just one at a time
like at our house but we also have I
also have a Zazzle store
that has like other kind of designs on
it I also have
um books that I because I write books
also like True Crime horror fiction all
that kind of stuff which are on Amazon
and
um also I have I design uh board games
board games and card games and that's on
the game crafter under giallo games
so we have like lots and lots of stuff
yeah uh Michael says cool thanks I will
tell you my temper is bad naturally and
my sex drive is high at my age I don't
want to have rages and all that no test
won't do that
if anything if you're like that that
might be a sign of low test test might
uh it it'll make you feel a lot better
you'll be more positive you might get
sexual there for a while
but you're always going to be like that
um probably but it um you have more of a
positive
spin on it okay
um you feel good so you're in a good
mood you don't get
Roid Rage or anything I've had all kinds
of [ __ ] Roid Rage but even that's not
that bad it's just
you get pissed
but you're not taking it that seriously
you know what it is when you're doing it
you know and it doesn't last long a few
seconds
and it usually is something that's
actually really is annoying that's
pissing me off it's not like you're
making it up
but it won't but test won't do that you
need to be on some powerful [ __ ] I mean
again that's like my normal state of
mind yeah always pissed off at something
but it's usually like really annoying
[ __ ] right okay
um on the amounts that they're giving
you like 200 milligrams of a week that's
that's a good dose but that's not enough
to make I mean
I can easily handle 500 milligrams of
testosterone a week that's no big deal
and you know a couple hundred milligrams
of [ __ ] Trenbolone a week on top of
that and then a bunch of other [ __ ] on
top of that
it's just no
you can handle it you just go get your
feet wet start slowly go business asking
about whey protein oh man [ __ ] whey
protein protein powders and all that
[ __ ] uh you have some of that though
yeah that will only help you if your
metabolism is working [ __ ] right and
if you're a low test male who's old
eating whey protein won't [ __ ] help
you at all you got to be either young
and working out or you've got to be old
and on [ __ ] tests or steroids for for
for whey protein to make any difference
all that is you're trying to get protein
into your system that's very low calorie
that's all you're trying to do but meat
is low calorie
and and like that shit's getting kind of
expensive man they want too much for
that whey protein man I can buy a
[ __ ] turkeys for less than that like
I said just eat those [ __ ] I love
eight of those [ __ ] turkeys yeah in
the freezer five dollars for a whole
[ __ ] turkey and then they want then
they want [ __ ] forty dollars for
[ __ ] five pounds of [ __ ] whey
protein man [ __ ] [ __ ] your time
seriously protein I would rather have
get those turkeys yeah yeah at least
that takes yeah it's good 40. I don't
want some [ __ ] Shake forty dollars a
[ __ ] forty dollars a turkey will give
you like [ __ ] 60 pounds of [ __ ] I
don't know how many uh five ten 40
pounds of turkey will give you 60 pounds
40 a turkey forty dollars a turkey would
give you five ten fifteen twenty twenty
oh man [ __ ] give you [ __ ] over 10
turkeys
each
how like how heavy was the turkey we
made for Thanksgiving five pounds was it
only five pounds no no that was almost a
ten pound I was gonna say that yeah but
like we ate on that for like a week yeah
yeah
I mean man and that was only like a ten
dollar turkey yeah yeah well like I said
and I was getting those five
this is cheap
protein here
turkey is actually a very good protein
because it's very lean 60 cents a pound
it was it was 42 cents a pound that's
right 42 cents it was 42.42 yeah Publix
had a big sale yeah so you can't beat
that there's no way Protein that's gonna
beat that [ __ ] and turkey tastes a
lot better yeah it's whey protein shakes
I don't know why I don't like any of
that kind of like I said I can't eat
that many calories in a day it's like if
I'm gonna eat some calories I want that
[ __ ] better be good yeah I don't want
some like [ __ ] [ __ ] protein shake
[ __ ] that if you're on gear man or
you're on gear you've been [ __ ]
lifting and [ __ ] you can sit up there
with a half a turkey [ __ ] like a lion
just eating that [ __ ] turkey that's
low calorie eye protein man just eating
turkey's good I feel like it's
underrated yeah people only eat it at
Thanksgiving and they don't eat turkey
anytime yeah I like I like I really like
turkey I like it better than chicken
actually man what was that what's that
[ __ ] meal that they were having to
look good you take a waffle
and then you [ __ ] put cheese on the
waffle and a big slab of turkey breast
and then the gravy what was that thing
called yeah it was what was the name of
that [ __ ] dish
wait are you talking about hot brown hot
brown I don't think that's a waffle
though is it I thought it was a waffle
it was a waffle or a pancake I thought
it was a waffle I mean even if it's not
that still sounds really good I'd eat
that I thought it had cheese
yeah it kind of sounds like a hot brown
yeah is that a head waffle with sweet
swiss cheese I think and then like a big
old slab of [ __ ] thick slab of turkey
breast on it and and gravy I've never
had a hot brown but I've seen like some
stuff about it and I'm just like uh you
look good that looks like that looks
like something I could I could uh be a
part of hot brown that's what they call
it yeah it's a hot brown I don't think
that it has anything what is it I
thought it was on a waffle I don't think
it is
that's what I'm saying if it's not our
waffle that I would say it should be on
a waffle I thought it was on a waffle
well because that would just be kind of
like chicken and waffles which is like a
very popular we were talking about that
too I was talking about that with my
siblings too because they were talking
about like I said my sister and my
brother like they're really really into
Disney and they've eaten at all the
restaurants and stuff like that so they
were recommending like some of the best
places like oh this place is the best
place to go for chicken and waffles and
this place is the best place to go for
ice cream and all that other kind of
stuff they know all that stuff El
padrino is [ __ ] uh thanking me thank
you very much you know just check it out
man you you'll you'll you'll like HRT
the Tammy's in this is I remember when
Tom started HRT because when I was on
the show I was like man I'm on HRT
you'll you'll feel a lot of relief
it's like a relief when it hits you yeah
about three weeks into it because at
first your body just forgot what to do
with it that you're injecting it and
it's going what's this
I kind of felt a little bit better when
I first did I don't know if it was
psychological but by week three it was
[ __ ] banging and I [ __ ] felt great
and that's when the change started and I
started getting more and more into into
the science
but um science sorry it's but uh El
padrino himself says look man I play the
commercials I'm interested to see him go
and play some courses okay but hold on
Michael says I relate to you guys Jenny
I grew up trailer trash and was in the
military yeah yeah well he was in the
military I was probably trailer trash
you weren't so much trailers yeah but
she's not as poor as she thinks she is
she came from a good family yeah they
were good yeah they were good people but
yeah we did we did like have zero money
when we were growing up so yeah we grew
up in a in a trailer park
we were either in a trailer park or we
had to live with relatives because both
my parents worked full-time but they
still didn't have enough because
after I'm the oldest but they eventually
had four children
so you know
it was it was it was a hard time
um all right so I kind of feel like
maybe I'll play some commercials okay
now if you guys have
subscribe to my scare Salon you've
probably seen a couple of these but I'll
put a couple of them on just for a
minute but I have to be here because
I don't have them all like in one thing
I just have to like play them one at a
time but I'll play a couple and then
when he gets back he can talk and then I
can go to the bathroom so hold on just a
minute we're gonna play some commercials
here we go
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right what's going on you guys like
them yeah there's just like a couple how
many more do we have in there
um I don't know I don't even remember
the ones I did I can always wish why are
you going to the restroom I could play
the rest of them um I don't I don't
trust you you don't trust me
I've done it four which is one with this
one's next right I don't I don't know
what about this one well no because okay
I did that one already yeah I did those
three yeah okay hold on just okay look
at this [ __ ] trying to micromanage I'm
not I'm just trying to manage
she's trying to manage it [ __ ]
okay go ahead I have to show you I have
to show you okay but you have to click
on them like when they're done right
yeah because it'll just go back I've
done this before look at this she's
trying to manage
I think all these are fair game all
right okay like that like from there
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
expired
[Music]
and darkness and decay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
they're well made movies uh somebody
said they just joined Tom shitty movies
I've been on Facebook in a while I gotta
go check that I mean for all I know a
bunch of people have requested to join
and I didn't [ __ ] accept it uh but
I'll get to it I'll go check it and I
think I gave everybody permission to
post stuff
so uh if you guys keep posts and stuff
and doing making comments or whatever in
on Tom shitty's movies I'll get in there
and [ __ ] deal with you
but uh yeah we've it's been a while
since I've since I've been on that one I
mean you haven't even done any like
shitty movies we haven't even talked
about you haven't even you haven't
talked about any Steven Seagal movies we
need to do a [ __ ] Steven Seagal
episode
a cigar he's gonna cut he's gonna show
up at our doors yeah he's trying to whip
my ass
well try that's the operative word yeah
that's a big dude I mean even though
he's [ __ ] old and fat he's still like
six well like I said he could probably
just like sit on you and you might
suffocate grab a hold of you and fall
down and roll over on you and [ __ ]
try to [ __ ] uh people have died like
do that [ __ ] face-sitting thing do
you see on porn where they [ __ ] sit
on a motherfucker's face
I got you now I don't want to think of
Steven Seagal and porn in the same
sentence dude man you know
the [ __ ] expert breast shiatsu
[ __ ] looking for breast [ __ ] uh I
can't [ __ ] believe he tried to pull
that [ __ ] for real huh
he's checking for breast cancer you know
I'm an expert shiatsu do you want me to
check for any lumps in your breast I
come on man that [ __ ] you got to
do better than that
I've seen photographs of that dude on
set [ __ ] talking to like girls that
were starring in movies with him that
he's funding and he's I was just looking
at them like just a [ __ ] total latch
like why yeah why does that not surprise
me like he totally comes around she's
just standing there trying to be
professional looking real like help
my Asian experience oh my God why
that is the best commercial of all times
although in in um Seagal's defense
I saw some recent material him on
YouTube and he is kind of making fun of
himself in some of the material so he FL
he finally like twigged onto the fact
that it's more like I think he's
realized that he's a meme
yeah basically yeah
that's well you know if that's true like
I'm not gonna go look because I don't
want that in my search history but I'm
just saying that it's like if that's
true then like respect because a lot of
dudes like that
um I kind of feel like they they never
get to a point where they can like
understand that like you know they they
need to like laugh at themselves
you know what I mean and I would have
thought that he was one of those dudes
the problem with Steven Seagal's movies
is that one he's not in them
two uh they're boring he's in there he's
just he's just kind of sitting there
mumbling about something he has he has
stunt doubles going up and down stairs
for him they only shoot him from the
shoulder up
they dub his voice
you know what why don't I do that maybe
I should get a stunt double to sit here
and do and like pretend to be me it
depends on the movie but it is because
they shoot some [ __ ] he wants them to
just make a movie around it you know a
lot of times because he doesn't want to
work yeah he's like I'm just gonna yeah
yeah yeah and this is like an eat a
burger he doesn't want to show up for
his own [ __ ] movie
I'll be in my trailer
come in my trailer and film me and then
like make a movie around yeah yeah
around him sitting in the in his lazy
boy yeah in the trailer
actually probably not even in the
trailer they probably have to like come
to his house wherever that is the last
one that I see he's like sitting in his
tub or some [ __ ] the last cigar movie I
saw I couldn't get through it it was
free on YouTube I think it was called
mercenary
yeah they're all about the same
mercenary For Hire mercenary for justice
mercenary prevention
mercenary for blood mercenary I could
just you can make that [ __ ] like I said
they should sell like one of those
[ __ ] like poetry magnet sets for like
Steven Seagal titles you could just
rearrange them on your fridge you know
and it had
oh man it was [ __ ] bad that was the
one where he's supposed to be a sniper
remember that his fat ass is supposed to
be a sniper and uh
man it's just
he's very badly overweight they won't sh
they won't shoot him except for like the
shoulder up well actually it's just kind
of like his face up yeah like his chin
up damn stunt double walking around from
the back so you know it's not him going
up and down because he's clearly like a
hundred pounds later yeah clearly a
hundred pounds like
they had that dude that was in under
siege that guy that was always on
[ __ ] CNN when I'm Admirals are a
general the white-haired dude he was
actually in Mars Attacks I think too not
Mars Attacks uh uh Invaders from Mars I
think he might have been in that he was
like the generic army guy the generic
yeah he's in it he was a consultant so I
think on a lot of things yeah and he's
like a hundred years old in it now
because that dude's [ __ ] anxious now
and everybody in this movie the youngest
person is probably like 50.
but in the rest of them are all in their
70s and 60s
and they're out
fighting mercenaries fighting in these
conflicts again just like old guys
pretending they're relevant the movie
yeah
they're in all their [ __ ] battle gear
and [ __ ]
and they're all out of shape all of them
and
in case you guys don't know Warfare is a
young man's game okay you want guys that
are about really you you want guys that
are between 13 and about 20. okay and
you say 13 you crazy the Africa did very
well with 13 12 13 14 year olds and
because they think they're Immortal they
don't think they can be killed so they
do a lot of Brave [ __ ] they're crazy
okay they're too dumb to know when
you're that young you're too dumb to
know uh about more yeah I understand
mortality yeah
so they do a [ __ ] good good job and
they look and young people love to have
a job and Status so they put they're all
into it
um now those guys happen to be in a
tribal Army but if you look at the
European history most of European
history is 13 14 year old 15 year old
guys the word infantry means boys
it's a [ __ ] French word young boys
baby Fighters yeah that's what they're
talking about battle babies battle
babies yeah battle baby ooh I'd watch
that cartoon yeah they don't really know
what's up
somebody make that cartoon and the
action figures because that would be all
about that battle babies but this is
like little infants with like all kind
of like [ __ ] Armor and kind of [ __ ]
on a little bit yeah I like that they'll
kill each other and [ __ ] kill
themselves and [ __ ] kill other people
for little strips of [ __ ] colored
cloth that they can put on their
uniforms you know
in that darling right but I was the same
way I was the same way I understand it
oh it's just the way the male mind works
especially when he's very young you know
yeah we know you're just hormonally
built for that
that's what was selected to survive
in in [ __ ] nature and you know
[ __ ] dog yeah I mean after you get to
a certain age we don't need y'all
anymore yeah so it's like y'all can just
like yeah they run after a mammoth and
run off yeah if you're like all right
Nails didn't evolve really
yeah beyond the age of about 25 right
that's
after that y'all just get in the win
yeah it's time for you to well it's not
getting away it's time for you to be
replaced by another a younger one
because it was just a conveyor belt it
was a conveyor belt of being replaced by
a younger Stronger Faster one that was
Dumber
because he didn't know faster Dumber
yeah because he didn't know he could die
you know he's a dude that would just run
right up really weird because I remember
like when I was a teenager actually when
I was a pre-teen I was very well aware
that I could die at any moment like not
a 15 or 16 year old boy I know well yeah
I know that like I was very well aware
of that also but it's like it just
seemed very funny to me like you guys
don't realize you can die okay all right
uh shawna's fan said Jenny are you going
to cover the Army Doctor Jeffrey
McDonald case convicted of murdering his
wife and three daughters
um yeah I could probably get into that
sure
um let's see uh they're talking about
Kelly LeBrock Tammy says put Pookie in a
blue wig you know what's funny Tammy is
that before we started the Stream
I was uh teasing Pookie because this is
a different I mean I've had this wig for
a while but this is like the I haven't
worn this one for a while so she was
like looking at me really funny like
when she came in the room she was like
looking at me like that and I was like
would you like me to get you a wig
Pookie and I was like I was talking
about how I was gonna get her a wig too
I don't think she would wear it though
we've all we always kind of talk about
getting her little outfit
but
I don't think she would wear them you
know oh you we got to put them on it's
nice that's what I'm saying she's just
gonna have like business she's not gonna
have that she likes being she might she
likes being neck there's no there's no
way no one she might she might
understand it immediately she's like oh
this is closed yeah I got clothes now
like yeah yeah she's crazy she is kind
of crazy well we're always kind of like
thinking of like what would be the best
outfit for her because she's kind of I
mean she's a pretty girl and everything
but she's uh kind of she's a little bit
of a tomboy yeah she's a little bit of
tomboy so I'm always kind of like
whenever we think about outfits for her
other day I was like oh she needs like a
little NASCAR racing outfit yeah like a
little like a little jumpsuit with like
STP and [ __ ] like like Evil Knievel used
to wear yeah that kind of seems like
like kind of her speed you know what I
mean that's like suits her personality I
think she ran she ran for us today yeah
you're sitting there and she just ran as
fast as she could and then she came back
like did you see yeah we saw did you see
yeah did you see I ran yeah I was coming
up the stairs because I was like do get
my laundry itches and she's like yeah
she did the whole show yeah put on a
whole show and then she goes she tears
the rug up yeah and she like looks yeah
see how fast yes
this is awesome
but yeah she needs some little outfits
but
she's not a real she's not a girly girl
Cookie's not well she's not a girl she's
a female cat yeah but I mean you know
well yeah but the thing about it is that
Beijing our other cat is very girly girl
yo she thinks she's Paris Hilton yeah
she definitely does yeah she's she's
kind of like yeah she's like too pretty
for everything she's just like whatever
she thinks she's just decoration
yeah sits around looks pretty don't
touch it
she is yeah she's like super fluffy
she's a rag doll by the way yeah
and yeah but she's like super fluffy and
she's always just kind of like laying
there like yeah she's also that's right
worship real dingy
a little bit yeah she's kind of digging
although she's kind of
time she acts like that but she's
actually a little bit cunning yeah like
on the down low yeah whereas Pookie is
very much
I mean she's like uh Pookie is like
really really intelligent but like I
said she's also kind of a tomboy a
little bit she likes a rough house well
she's like a dog
she is kind of like a puppy yeah a
little bit it's just in the descriptions
of manx cats it says they're dog-like
yeah she is very she is kind of dog-like
yeah like not quite as high maintenance
I feel like as a dog but
almost because I mean she pretty much
wants attention like all the time when
she's not sleeping if she's awake she
wants some like [ __ ] attention she's
in your [ __ ] face she's in your
[ __ ] face all the time like I'm like
over there working on my desk she's like
hey I'm gonna jump up on your keyboard
and sit on it hey what's up and she will
not move how long's the stream been
going
three hours okay it's time for us to
shut it down time for us to go we're
gonna get something to eat
yeah I'm kind of hungry yeah all right
so hopefully you guys had a good time
this evening on this Friday night
uh we're gonna take the day off tomorrow
right yeah yeah yeah and then we'll be
back Sunday talking about a movie I
don't know which one yet
but we'll see how it goes we're gonna go
get something to eat so you guys have a
good rest of your evening have a good
day tomorrow and thanks everybody for
dropping by thanks for your super chats
and all of that remember to like And
subscribe and all of that kind of stuff
if you haven't done that already
and we'll see you guys again on Sunday
evening good night